okay we'll open up the public hearing
and house bill 1404 and hear from the
prime sponsor representative invented to
speak
uh i submitted house bill 1404 at the
request of a contentious constituent in
manchester
i am going to request that this
committee itl the bill
as written but i would like to speak as
to why it was presented mr chairman
um
the individual came to me very upset
about some issues that occurred
and um i'd like to
explain that an individual had their car
towed from their apartment complex
uh the apartment complex com
blamed the tow company said well we give
them the right to do that if cars are
largely illegally parked that was not
the case
uh and it was a well
i want you to pay for it as your
landlord no i'm not gonna pay for it
well why did you let them tow my car
whose fault is it and then i got into
that but that wasn't that was only part
of the problem the other problem is the
individual had to pay to get their car
from the tow company but in their
vehicle were some of their personal
items including the only thing they
could do on a saturday morning was a
debit card
sorry that was mom
um
it was a debit card guess what the debit
card was in the car
so they went to get the car and they
said what's 40 dollars to us to let you
go in and get your personal items from
your vehicle well i don't have forty
dollars i need my debit card
to be able to get the money
to get the car out
well go borrow it from someone
really i have to go borrow forty dollars
from a friend to get into my car to pay
you to get into my car so i can get my
debit card to go to the bank to get the
money to pay my car
out of hock
that was towed
from my apartment complex when my car
was parked legally with a sticker on my
car
so obviously she was quite upset
she presented a bill which i have in
front of you which i had requested some
of the stuff be taken out by
legislative services
but we all know what happened last year
when everything was put together in one
week
i would never put a bill forth that
would have a price tag on something
because then what happens is we all know
in the legislature if you put a price
tag on something that has to be always
amended year after year after year with
inflation or what have you
regardless
then representative excuse me gary
abbott from the agc explained to me that
a bill had passed last year
rules and laws regarding towing both
mostly for commercial
so i wanted you to hear that story
there are bad apples in every industry
in the insurance industry
where i sit
every once in a while we have a
situation and that's why the insurance
commissioner can take our licenses away
if we if we don't follow the rules
this was a really bad situation
it shouldn't have happened it shouldn't
happen again i don't think it rises to
the level that we need to go after
everybody that does follow the rules and
is compassionate about what they do and
are responsible for how they operate
their towing business but it's a bad
story that i wanted to do at least here
that being said
i'm happy to take your questions but i
respectfully request
that you take my bill and
put it in the trash can and i tell it at
your earliest convenience today would be
preferable
mr chairman
okay we have any questions from the
committee members saying none thank you
very much come on over to labor whenever
okay so given that the uh
the sponsor would like the bill to die
and every card i have in front of me is
uh opposed to the bill
i would just uh say that uh
the model of brevity would be
appreciated uh so uh brittany
shoot
little t
from the yes from the front of a motor
we always honor every card you can say i
have nothing to say
good morning well i'm brittany schue i
am here on behalf of the division of
motor vehicles bureau of title and
anti-theft after that i wasn't quite
sure if what i had to say would add to
that at all
um
we
at our pose as written um it's
introducing 265 108-a
this uh statue already exists as parade
vehicles and that's the biggest
fault that we found with this
we do feel that people should be able to
obtain their vehicles without exorbitant
fees
but aside from that mostly 265 108-a
already exists in statute
and with that i'll be happy to take any
questions
do you have any questions
oh we do have a question representative
abel i i just wanted to know if the uh
existing statute
uh would deal deal how it deals with
this uh this kind of instance
thank you for your question the current
statute um 265 108 a is per for parade
vehicles
great thank you very much thank you
chair we'll call on ralph
creston
all right i'm ralph creston new
hampshire towing association i'm the
president of the association
the association's opposed to this bill
uh we can't afford this bill
to do toes from what
that bill was designed for and i
understand it's going to be dropped
but our personnel cost too much money
the trucks cost too many much money the
insurance cost too much money everything
has just gone crazy as everybody well
knows
at this point so we we really can't
afford to do
this kind of towing for the price that
great
any questions
ain't none thank you very much
uh chair we'll call on devin carlos
take us
history
yeah do you hit the button
there you go hi good morning
my name is devin karkos from new
hampshire towing association i'm a
director
and i'm from bob's automotive in dover
we are opposed to the bill for pricing
as ralph mentioned um
what most of our drivers are paid on
commission based on tows sometimes day
and night and it would be unaffordable
and unobtainable to get drivers to be
able to handle these type of calls for
that situation and as ralph mentioned
with insurance and other costs
increasing
it would probably limit the amount of
companies doing that
one side effect would be a lot of
property management places not being
able to get cars dealt with and having
to move cars for like snow and ice
removal reasons it it probably would see
a big downturn in having toilet
companies be willing to take this on
and not be able to get parking lots
cleared for safety reasons afterwards
because we just couldn't handle it for
fair enough so thank you thank you
and one more card left bob clegg
yeah okay
all right
uh the blue sheets uh you know a bunch
of people were all opposed to it
and overnight there was two supporters
for this bill overnight
and the rest were uh three were opposed
and with that i will close the public
hearing
and
just so you all know
unlike
other committees in the senate this
committee does not kill bills the same
day
we deserve every bill should have 24
hours
uh
sometimes little things come up that
makes us you know want to do something
else with the bill and use it as a
vehicle so we we generally like to hold
hold
hold it so we don't have to have a
non-germane hearing if something were to
okay we'll open up the public hearing on
house bill 1413 and hear from the prime
sponsor representative wilbur good
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee uh thank you for having me and
thank you for considering house bill
1413.
uh i'll tell you this is my uh i don't
know what it is third or fourth attempt
to try and do something on the in the
realm of internet privacy
my previous uh
iterations didn't come to this committee
they went to the judiciary committee
because they were framed in terms of
privacy in a different way and so that's
where they went they've been successful
in the house and unsuccessful in the
senate
for various reasons which we don't need
to deal with
so
having excepted from other states laws a
couple times i did it again
and this is uh basically
uh the maine law that's been on the
books now for six or seven years
and according to my information has been
challenged in federal court and has
stood although it hasn't gone beyond the
district court level
so
this bill
attempts to
provide a
degree of privacy to you as an internet
user
by going to
[Music]
the provider of the service that you're
going to use
so it starts out and if you look at a
provider
on line 28
the provider means a person who provides
in
broadband internet access service
which is defined in roman one on line
six
and it's any mass-market retail service
by wire or radio that provides the
capability to transmit and receive data
from pretty much anybody on the internet
so it's your phone company it's your
cable company if you get internet access
through your cable it's uh whoever it is
if you're dealing through satellite
whoever's providing you the access
that's where this bill is targeted
because they're the ones to whom you are
bound
i mean and you are really practically
their slaves in terms of what you can
what you do on the internet every single
thing that you do goes through them
and they have the ability to extract and
information from that of sorts that you
wouldn't even think they would want or
would you have any value
but they turn out to be of great value
like your location where you just happen
to be at that particular time because
that can be taken and correlated with
other people who are in the same place
and we can find out everybody you ever
talked to in your entire life
when and where and probably what you
were talking about through other means
of stuff that we can get that you do
through the internet
uh
so
so the risk
to our
this is kind of like inherent in our
privacy we don't have the right to
record other people
we expect
when you're not in a setting such as
this
that
nobody else has the right to
know what we're doing
but yet
this data that's being collected
is exactly that
they know they can know pretty much
everything you're doing
when where why with whom and all of that
so to try and get corral that somewhat
use
the information that they can gather
for any purposes
except for those which you gave it to
them
right they can't sell it
transmit it or even allow access one of
the great and i think
travesties in our systems right now
is that
the government
can just pick drop a dime and say oh i
want to know everybody's cell phone who
was in washington dc in the on a certain
day
or around the governor's house on a
certain time in a certain time period
right
or at your house
oh no
they know who's at your house but the
so
this bill intends to curtail that
at the source
where you are entering into the internet
that is the provider
and
it includes great
exceptions for all the important uses
from lines 16 to
30 on the second page
and i won't waste your time going
through all of those but it's all the
ones you would expect and no one's in
subject to a warrant or
to render and bill for services
they can even provide your geolocation
in case of emergencies
to certain entities but always for your
benefit
always and only for your benefit
and it includes a penalty section as it
has to do
which we have how we have elevated to
the attorney general's office to enforce
and the reason we did that is because
these are big people that we're talking
about regulating
and you and i would not want to go to
court against comcast
or
any other of these
providers there are some some
provisions of this bill like how they
protect your data
that does allow flexibility for the size
of the provider
so
down on lines 33-37
on page two it talks about implementing
security
measures
and the factors that have to be
considered in one of those is the scope
of the provider's activity
right so if it's a small provider
then they probably don't have to
implement the security measures that
i'll just use comcast again might have
um
so with that i uh i guess i'll take a
couple questions uh i would like to keep
this brief
because i'm absent from my committee
right now and i'm the clerk so it makes
it hard for me when i'm here
okay no problem representative
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
there's no fiscal note um on this bill
um
could you
i don't understand i mean it really will
affect the attorney general's office can
you comment on that
so i don't uh
derive fiscal notes and they don't make
a lot of sense to me a lot of times but
i will just say that nobody has any idea
how many claims might come up or what
involvement it might take for the
attorney general to solve this and so
they probably just said ah there's
nobody oh i do have something uh i
looked at the online testimony on this
yesterday
and uh richard head testified that
because it creates a new cause of action
the senate the effective date has to be
moved out but you have that testimony
okay any other questions of
representative burroughs
thank you and thank you for taking my
question and i'm asking this i actually
don't totally understand about cookies
and how they're used but yeah cookies
that's we're better off eating them just
say no
i got excited when they asked me if i
wanted them i always said yes but
my question is and and you may not you
may know
as much as i do but
i'm increasingly seeing that sites are
making you accept cookies before you can
use them making you accept
to say that that they'll use you they
can use your data and i don't know if
that goes to the internet provider or
not when you do that
or is it just on the website that you're
browsing
so
there's a provision in this bill
that says they cannot deny you service
unless they've made clear
and explicit
what their what information they're
going to
sell
which does not include your personal
information there's lots of other
information that's out there and they
have to make clear to you they're going
to sell that
uh which would be the same type of thing
but that they can't deny you service
this denial of service for failure to
allow them to put something on your
machine that you have no idea what it's
really going to do but they say it's
only gonna oh we'll know when the last
time you came and what you looked at
i'm i don't like it
one time we i tried to build it said
they couldn't do that
and it came to this committee and they
they have that
myself when they ask for cookies
i never say
yes and if they won't let me do anything
i go somewhere else there's another
internet side i can find what i want
thank you so you're sticking with
of course it could be girl scout
cookies some of those s'mores
okay
well thank you very much we'll let you
go thank you
all right so since he was mentioned
nice to see you again richard it's great
to see you again mr chairman uh my name
is richard head i'm the government
affairs coordinator for the judicial
branch
and as the representative mentioned i
did submit written testimony i have
a fairly simple request which relates to
the effective date of the bill if this
bill is to proceed there's a statute
actually that governs effective dates
that i referenced in my in my letter of
testimony i submitted rsa 14 colon 9a
is a specific statute that addresses
effective dates
and there's a provision in that where if
the bill impacts the judicial branch
either policies practices or adds or
deletes
civil or criminal remedies
the effective date should be january 1
of the following year
and i like speaking to big committees
because all of you are also submitting
legislation so it's something to keep in
mind anytime you are you are putting
legislation forward
i do this probably 30 40 times
a session
so the extent i can reduce that it's
helpful um and the reason is is fairly
simple from our end
you know this is one bill of many many
bills um and so for example if a
criminal provision is changed or there's
a new civil provision that's added
we have a database that has a line for
every criminal action
and then within criminal actions like
for example if it's a drug case
the weight sometimes affects the the
nature of what the penalty can be so
there you know one line in a in a
criminal statute can have three or four
lines in our database the same is true
with civil causes of action and this
particular bill adds a civil cause of
action so from our end we need to be
able to both adjust our systems but also
engage in training for our judges our
staff
and what have you
so a long-winded way of asking for if
this bill is to go forward that the
effective date be modified to january 1
2023 and with that i'd be happy to
answer any questions
uh we do have a question representative
bartlett thanks mr chair i'm sorry i
didn't catch your government affairs
judicial branch of what so the state of
new hampshire court system thank you
and richard used to be brendan's job
and
following me you should listen to him
carefully
so nice to see you again thank you
so now we'll have brandon
come up so we got department of justice
good morning
everybody hear me okay
uh good morning mr chairman members of
the committee my name is brandon garad
i'm a senior assistant attorney general
chief of the consumer protection and
anti-trust bureau at the new hampshire
attorney general's office
my testimony this morning is limited to
the last section of this bill which if
effective would be
rsa 359 t9 which is labeled penalties
and enforcement
so as the sponsor indicated this bill
anticipates
putting this new statute in the hands of
the attorney general's office for
enforcement it does not indicate a
specific
bureau that would enforce it however
given the nature of the legislation
i suspect they would likely fall to the
consumer protection bureau as it is
essentially a consumer protection issue
that it's um addressing
so as the potential enforcer of this
bill i think it's incumbent on the
attorney general's office to point out
that the way the penalties and
enforcement section of this bill is
currently drafted
would render it essentially
unenforceable at all by the attorney
general's office and i'll explain why
for the consumer protection anti-trust
bureau our authority to investigate
potential
violations of law largely comes from rsa
358-a which is the new hampshire
consumer protection act
which makes it unlawful to engage in
unfair and deceptive acts or practices
in the course of commerce and if
something is either specifically labeled
as an unfair and deceptive act of
practice in the course of commerce or
fits that general definition the
attorney general then has the ability to
compel live testimony of witnesses to
compel documents to conduct an
investigation in order to determine
whether a violation has actually
occurred and if through our
investigation we're able to prove that
an unfair and deceptive act or practice
has occurred we then have significant
enforcement authority
civil or criminal penalties around the
table
injunctive relief fines potentially jail
time if it's a criminal case
but the way this is currently worded
nothing about this puts
a violation of this statute
specifically under new hampshire's
consumer protection act it does not make
it an unfair and deceptive act or
practice in commerce does not
specifically say that it will be
enforced under the consumer protection
act so therefore the ability to issue a
subpoena to compel testimony to enter
into an investigation assuming we
receive a complaint of this we would
essentially have no authority to compel
anything from the business
which is obviously problematic when as
the sponsor noted you're dealing with
large corporations such as comcast
verizon uh companies that are not
exactly going to show up as a willing
participant participant to sit down and
engage in a voluntary interview with the
attorney general's office to determine
whether they violated new hampshire law
so i suggest that you know
the way it's currently written the way i
would see it playing out is a consumer
could come to the attorney general's
office and say
there's been a violation of the statute
i'd like you to enforce it
our ability to investigate would
essentially be limited to what the
consumer was able to provide us
and what the business was voluntarily
willing to give us and and that's not
really an effective way for us to
enforce a statute like this i think that
if this is to go forward there needs to
be serious consideration about
how the attorney general's office is
going to have the authority to do a
meaningful investigation of complaints
when they come in because right now the
way it's written i i really don't see
that we'd be able to do the level of
thorough investigation that we do
whenever we receive consumer complaints
the the second issue that i'll point out
is that this
statute in in terms of penalties and
enforcement
limits the available tools to the
attorney general's office as a thousand
dollar fine for a violation
under the consumer protection act an
unfair and deceptive act or practice is
punishable by a fine of up to ten
thousand dollars per violation as well
as the ability to receive injunctive
relief and the ability like i said if
it's criminal case to impose jail time
and the attorney general's office
retains that discretion
based on the investigation the level of
the conduct the the mental state of the
bad actor how many complaints we
received to have all those tools in our
toolbox to enforce the statute and
really seek justice to ensure that the
bad actor
a doesn't act this way again in order to
protect consumers and be as punished
on a level consistent with the bad
action that's taken
i i would suggest that the ability for
the attorney general's office to impose
a civil penalty that can't exceed a
thousand dollars likely would not do
much to deter large corporations like
comcast
and would really bootstrap the attorney
general's office at a very very limited
enforcement authority to be able to do
anything about potential violations of
the statute essentially it would allow
corporations to simply make this go away
by paying a fine and you know a fine
that really in the grand scheme of
things is significantly less than the
fine that the legislature has
anticipated as appropriate for
violations of the consumer protection
act ten thousand dollars per violation
and as you know significantly more um if
it's a private right of action brought
by a citizen depending on the the mental
state of the company
so i i think that the if this goes
forward the i would encourage the
legislature to consider um whether it
makes sense to keep this as a thousand
dollar fine or whether it should be
expanded to allow the attorney general's
office to use its discretion um
in
seeking appropriate injunctive relief
certainly this wouldn't even give us the
ability to get a court order an
injunction to prevent the conduct from
happening in the future would simply
allow us to take a fine
and the final issue was pointed out you
know this
ascribes a new responsibility to the
attorney general's office of of the type
that we have not previously seen before
there was no fiscal note done so if this
is passed it raises the question of
additional resources
we don't know how many complaints we
would receive
we don't know how difficult or
time-consuming these investigations
would be
so it's an indeterminate fiscal impact
at this point but it is likely to
significantly increase the number of
complaints that come into the bureau and
that very well may pose the need for
additional resources if this is
something that the attorney general's
office has asked to enforce
that's pretty much the synopsis of my
testimony if there's any questions happy
any questions from the committee
so um
humor because i i it is true i've never
seen this uh pay much attention to the
penalty
uh to negotiate and to settle with
suspected violators without court action
have you ever seen that before in in any
legislation that
so i i can't i i
have not seen it in legislation uh it's
certainly not present in any of the
statutes that the bureau currently
enforces forces
currently if if we want to impose a fine
i would have to be done either through a
civil complaint and a consent judgment
that that settles
that where the fine is agreed upon or
file a civil complaint go to trial
receive an order from the court
requiring the company to impose the fine
or it could be agreed upon
through what's called an assurance of
discontinuance which is a tool that's
anticipated under the consumer
protection act that allows us to settle
with an offending business or individual
not really if it's filed with the court
so there is some level of court
involvement but it doesn't have the same
court approvals that are necessary for a
civil complaint consent judgment but no
language like that
is not something that we see in the
statutes that we enforce i haven't seen
first time i've ever seen it
okay
any questions the committee see none
thank you very much thank you
all right uh chris
good morning
good morning can you you spell your last
name so we make sure we get it right
sure yeah it's uh
thanks for the opportunity uh to testify
uh my name is chris gilrayne i'm with
technet
we are an industry
organization representing a wide array
of companies throughout the innovation
ecosystem from internet service
providers
autonomous vehicles cloud computing
clean energy and more
the one thing that really unites all of
these very disparate industries is an
interest and a stake in data privacy
our members place a high priority on
consumer privacy and for that reason uh
we are investing significant time and
resources into advancing a federal
standard that would with have clear
rights and responsibilities when it
comes to consumer protection and data
protection for all americans
whether we like it or not there is no
internet of new hampshire or vermont or
even california there is a borderless
ecosystem and privacy laws should be
handled at the federal level in
recognition of that
fortunately in the case of hp 1413 the
specific data and practices that this
bill is seeking to restrict the use of
is already well protected under a number
of federal standards
beginning with the ftc standards the
federal trade commission
and a patchwork of other federal privacy
laws
including
coppa
the
controlling assault of non-solicited
pornography and marketing act
security breach and unfair practices
laws as well
our concern is that the broad
restrictions and the use of consumer
data could throw into question a wide
range of everyday processes that
underpin the customer experience here in
new hampshire
combined with a private right of action
the broadness and vagueness of some of
the language here and could cause a
significant liability risk for companies
particularly at a time when
the federal money coming in is uh
allowing these companies to focus on
expanding their networks expanding the
infrastructure and connecting
more granite state residents
that should be the focus is connecting
residents as opposed to uh
being concerned about potential massive
liability
and that is a significant concern
particularly when we pair it with the
private right of action we've seen it uh
in a number of states
privacy laws are complex and open to
interpretation
and when it's paired with the private
right of action we've seen
in illinois under their biometrics law
in california under their privacy law
a lot of settlement-seeking behavior
that really benefits nobody but the pr
the plaintiffs bar
uh
to that end i'll i'll wrap up i i know
there are a lot of people behind me um
but i appreciate your time
great thank you any questions see none
thank you very much oh richard yes
representative abel thank you um i just
wanted to make sure i i understood you
correctly did you say that there are
federal
laws that already cover this and if so
could you just
tell us a little bit about that
yeah the main
umbrella is the ftc standard um
but when it comes to specific uh pieces
of data that are called out in the
bill
particularly when it comes to the
information of miners that falls under
kappa
and geolocation data already covered
and so the it's the ftc is the big
umbrella but there are other specific
laws that cover some of the specific
information that's uh that's delineated
okay great thank you
jerry recall on
nancy
levin
good morning good morning thank you
i think my testimony is being
distributed right now
well good morning chair hunt vice chair
patusik and distinguished members of the
committee thanks for the chance to
testify today
my name is nancy libben and i'm a
partner at the law firm of davis wright
tremaine
where i co-chair the technology
communications privacy and security
practice
before private practice i was the chief
privacy officer at the u.s department of
justice where i was part of an
interagency task force
that developed a framework for consumer
data privacy in the 21st century
which has been supported and implemented
by democratic and republican
administrations
i am here today on behalf of ncta the
internet and television association
which is the principal trade association
for the u.s broadband and paid
television
industries i want to start by commending
the committee for examining a very
important issue and very complicated
issue of consumer privacy
hb 1413 is well-intentioned but it is
problematic
in a number of ways
in large part because
it diverges from the well-settled
approach taken by
the federal trade commission on a
bipartisan basis and virtually every
other existing privacy regime
the ftc framework was designed to
protect consumers and preserve companies
ability to innovate and provide their
services
the approach in this bill
would undermine both of those goals and
would have a number of unintended
consequences some of which i'd like to
highlight for the committee today
first
the bill does not cover all commercial
entities in the online marketplace that
handle personal information it covers
only broadband providers
which have a strong record of protecting
their customers privacy
and does not regulate edge providers
such as search engines social media
networks mobile apps or companies that
collect use and disclose large amounts
of consumer information like data
brokers and online ad networks
leaving these other entities free to use
consumer internet browsing history
real-time geo-location information
and so forth to target ads and for other
purposes
it therefore fails to protect consumers
in the area where their privacy is most
at risk
nor does the bill explain how consumers
would be protected against mishandling
of personal information by third parties
that receive personal information
that is precisely what happened in the
cambridge analytica incident a few years
ago
that sparked much of the concern about
these issues over the last several years
yet the bill fails to address that
the bill also would impede legitimate
business activities
it treats all personal information
regardless of that information's
sensitivity
the same way
requiring companies to obtain express
affirmative opt-in consent before using
disclosing or making available such
information to any person
regardless of and without exception for
the consumer's expectations or the
context in which the personal
information was collected
but not all data if misused or
wrongfully disclosed has the same
potential to harm consumers
a social security number or health
related information is not the same as a
device's ip address
which is why the ftc's privacy framework
and virtually all other recently enacted
state privacy laws in california
colorado and virginia
and even the european union's rigorous
general data protection regulation
apply different levels of consent to
sensitive and non-sensitive data
in addition broadband providers like
other companies typically analyze
information regarding the use of their
services to improve those services and
to develop new products and services
they also use such information to
protect their networks from bad actors
the ftc recognized that these activities
were consistent with the context in
which companies collect information from
consumers
and that consent to engage in those
activities could therefore be inferred
this bill however would require
providers to get opt-in consent from
customers before using their information
for such purposes
this could actually harm consumers by
for example depriving them of offers for
discounted prices
or other ways to reduce their costs and
it would impair innovation by depriving
businesses of helpful information that
they need to design and improve their
products and services in a way that
appeals to consumers
other provisions of the bill are
unworkable for companies
you will hear later this morning about
how pervasive encryption of internet
traffic makes consumers online activity
largely invisible to isps
this is by design and it's an important
security protection that has been
developed over time
yet this bill would make isps
responsible for obtaining consent before
making consumer personal information
available to other entities
this would be an impossible task without
undermining the various security
protections that have been put in place
to protect consumers
the bill also applies to any individuals
located in new hampshire
but the companies won't always know
where consumers are located
this will require companies to track the
location of individuals to determine
whether the law applies again
undermining rather than protecting
consumers privacy
moreover the use of precise geo-location
information is prohibited under the bill
absent express affirmative consent from
the consumer or when it is used for one
of several emergency purposes
providers would not even know from whom
they would need to obtain consent
because they would be precluded from
using the location of their mobile
customers for this purpose
in addition the definition of customer
personal information is overbroad and
appears not to have any limiting
principle
it can be read to capture any
information from a customer's use of the
internet access service
this potentially includes virtually all
information that broadband subscribers
generate when they use broadband
services including data that doesn't
identify and can't be linked to a
specific individual
the bill also allows consumers to direct
providers not to use disclose or make
available information that is not
customer personal information
in combination these provisions would
actually preclude providers from
offering services to their customers
of course i'm not sure i'm sure that's
not the intent of the bill but that is
how it currently reads
in addition the bill prohibits companies
from making consent to use and disclose
personal information a condition of
providing a service
but isps need to use and disclose
personal information to third parties in
order to provide their services
for example isps must disclose ip
addresses when they deliver emails
hb 1413
will provide consumers with no
protection against the misuse of
personal information by social networks
and companies like google that as the
headlines government enforcement actions
record fines and widespread litigation
both here and abroad have shown are the
biggest drivers of public concern over
online privacy
the result will be consumer confusion
and frustration as consumers learn that
the rights afforded to them in this bill
offered them no protection against
virtually all other businesses operating
in new hampshire online including the
largest abusers of their personal
information
finally an identical law currently in
effect in maine is the subject of
litigation on the grounds that it
violates the first amendment of the u s
constitution
at issue is the very approach that hb
1413 takes here namely the regulation
of the use and disclosure of data
by one category of speaker isps and isps
alone
discovery and briefing on the merits in
that case is underway and a decision is
likely to be issued later this year or
early next year
at the very least we ask that new
hampshire defer its current process
regarding this bill until the main case
has been resolved
thanks very much for the opportunity to
testify today i'd be happy to answer any
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
okay chair we'll call on
maura weston and
representing new england cable and
good morning members of the committee
yeah come on you have to talk because
you got a real good mass there you got
to talk
louder
can you hear me chairman hunt yes
wonderful thank you
good morning my name is maura weston i'm
here this morning on behalf of the new
england cable and telecommunications
association
our members include breezeline
formerly known as atlantic broadband
charter
and comcast
our members
are the leading broadband and
communication providers in new hampshire
they serve approximately 485 000
customers
and offer services to more than
650 000 locations in more than 184
communities
we are testifying today in opposition to
house bill 1413.
as drafted
the bill's privacy protections targeted
are targeted only at internet service
providers
as you've heard this is neither legally
permissible
nor effective
if the goal
is to protect the privacy of consumers
this bill will not achieve that goal
most importantly
the bill fundamentally misunderstands
the role of isps
and when and where consumer data
is accessible
on behalf of necta
my goal is not only to share with you
our broad concerns
about this legislation but to ensure
that you have access
to the expertise
to expertise in this subject matter
so with that i'd like to introduce you
to brian scriber he is a distinguished
technologist and vice president of
security and privacy technologies at
cable labs
which is a not-for-profit global
innovation and r d lab
for the broadband cable industry
so we thank you very much for your
attention and after brian gives his
remarks we're happy to answer any
questions
good morning chairman hunt and
distinguished members of the committee
um
as maura introduced i'm brian scriber
and i am a professional nerd so i
i i keep your secrets safe uh is what i
i tell folks the
um
the work that we do at cable labs as
maura mentioned is very focused on
security and privacy of subscribers when
they are online
and i'm going to talk today about some
of the technologies
that are in place and how technology has
changed in the last 15 years
to create a very different environment
from the kind of i think mindset that
came into play for writing this bill and
the
the the pieces of when we start talking
about
um the
the deck that i think now everybody has
has the the deck that's come through
so the house bill 1413 lists nine
categories of information that the bill
wants isps to protect uh the handout
explains technological capabilities of
isps to access each of those categories
for many of the listed categories isps
can neither see nor protect or do
anything with that data and that is by
design the security in place the https
uh when you on the browser see that lock
icon
when you are online that is a
relationship between you
and the end point the isp does the job
of moving bits across the the wire
but we don't see
the encrypted data between you and that
website and that website that you visit
can have information can have scripts
that run that advise other websites
about who you are and what you did on
previous websites that is information
that is completely invisible to the
service provider that is doing the job
of carrying those bits across for you so
i wanted to make sure
if if there was one thing that i i
uh helped the committee understand today
is technology has changed from when
this may have have had some some more
sense to its applicability today
that encryption and the invisibility of
your interactions online to the isps
make this a step backwards
and it puts the isps back in a spot
where we have to start cracking open
things and working to try to figure out
how your
um your your interactions online could
better be protected that actually
is like i said i think a step in the
wrong direction for how we want to do
this so the security and privacy
technologies team at cable apps how do
we get people more protected how do we
get you more encryption
and how do we get there
of consumer time online
is over an encrypted channel
that is a tremendous change from where
we were 15 years ago when you were
looking at about 30
of that traffic being encrypted there
has been a massive upswell in the
adoption of https of messaging services
these are all
protecting
the transit layer so the isp that
carries that traffic
all we see are very random looking bits
that we we have no ability to to dive
into
i want to focus for a second on
i think it's slide
5 shows the
networking layers and on this one
they're
they're without without diving into a
full networking course
there are seven networking layers the
top three the application presentation
and session layer that's where like
that's how you as a user on the internet
interact with things you're using an
application you're using email you're
browsing you're going to a website
you're using a messaging service like
signal or telegram
any of those activities where you're on
google where you're on duckduckgo all of
that activity happens in
that layer um
and then it's encrypted everything below
that that's where cable isps
exist so this is where the transport the
network the data link and the physical
layer
this is what we worry about and how we
how we make sure traffic gets delivered
and it's it's confidential it's
integrity hasn't so nobody's changed the
messages you've sent and um that it's
that it's always available so
confidentiality integrity and
availability that's where we focus on
those lower layers but the slide before
this is slide four and on on that slide
um
this is where
uh we we dive into the nine categories
of information that we want to protect
and this is i think an important one to
kind of walk through
if we take a look at the column for
cable isp visibility there are
several of these
financial information we never see it so
we can't protect it we
we can't see that info
the customer's health information we
can't see it we can't advise you that
you are releasing your information on a
website because we don't know what's
happening inside that website
the information pertaining to your
children not visible the content of your
communications what you texted what you
sent not visible
from a pure technology perspective when
we look at the rest of this there's some
complicated nuance in some of these and
again i i won't dive into
the the hyper details on this but
customer web browsing history is
important to point out
the isp is not your browser right that
browser is a piece of software that you
install on your computer and that
software um in the case of chrome which
is uh the the most used browser that's a
piece of software that that google has
written and and published so google's
interaction with you at that layer then
becomes encrypted
and we don't see anything other than
potentially a look up to see how to
deliver traffic so if you were to go to
cablelabs.com
and type that into your browser there's
a something called a dns lookup where we
check to see what is effect it's kind of
like a phone book right you look up a
name and you get back a number well
that's what dns does it says here's the
routing number for cablelabs.com and
then your traffic is encrypted and goes
over that we don't know what pages
inside cablelabs.com you were to visit
we don't know
what
forms you fill out any of the messaging
that happens so our ability to protect
as this bill is is written becomes
pretty problematic when we're talking
about an encrypted exchange so um
the
that's the why there's a limited right
there's some level of information about
this that the isp has that's actually
diminishing as
dns itself is becoming encrypted so
that's
increasingly difficult to engage in as
well
customer application usage history
for network optimization perspectives
and um and the ability to do again some
of this lookup if you are
we may know that you have gone to a site
like netflix and that there's a lot of
traffic that's coming down and we may
need to reconfigure the network to be
able to optimize it so that that traffic
comes down so that your experience
online is as positive as it can be so
there's some information we don't know
what you watched on netflix we don't
know how you interacted with netflix but
we do know that hey you're
there there's still a good amount of
traffic that we have to deliver to your
end point from from that net end point
the as far as customers precise
geo-location information um from a
terrestrial
uh cable hybrid fiber coax perspective
like if you have uh uh comcast or a
charter uh deployment there is a cable
that runs from the head end all the way
out to your house
and so with that we do know where we
deliver service
but we do not know
where you are we just know this is where
we send the bill and this is where we
send the bits so um that's the the limit
of um
geo-location information that a
terrestrial cable company has um as we
go down this list though there's two
other places where there's a yes
device identifiers
and this is
devices that connect to the internet
we do know some information about those
devices
in in some cases
that is to secure that connection uh and
if those devices participate in ddos
activities or botnets we may need to
advise the the home user hey there is a
device that
matches this description can you take a
look at it update the firmware you know
whatever may need to happen if you're
participating in a a botnet uh so very
sis it's critical to deliver the service
um and so we do have some of that
information but that is
for the the the purpose of delivering
secure and and private service uh as far
as the origin and destination internet
protocol addresses i want to spend one
second on this one because i think it's
such an important part of how this bill
is written and the protection of an ip
address if you'll take a look in the
slide deck
two slides later there's
packets and visibility and on that slide
you'll see every every internet packet
that gets delivered
has
a
a a header that looks like this part of
that header that source address and
destination address
this is
just like us mail
and i think it's a great analogy to use
when we're talking about how we deliver
traffic
the us mail has to have the address you
expect this thing to get to
and your return address hey if something
goes wrong if they aren't there
get it back to me
that is exactly the same model here and
in fact the analogy does so well that
the bottom of this when you see that
data section at the bottom
that is the encrypted data it's inside
the envelope and it's sealed
so
in this analogy the post office can't
make sure you're not getting junk mail
right because it doesn't know what's
inside the envelope
and you have to have this information
for the delivery so with the the
destination address i have to know where
to carry those bits for you and with the
return address if there's errors or that
site that you gave the information to
so i think that the um
i think we we've pretty much wrapped up
the the key parts of this um
the
um
i think
based on some of the the other testimony
this morning
um when we talk about
uh the bad actors i i think it's
i think it's salient to bring up that
that
is when a a user is interacting on a
uh end point a website that is sharing
their information
that bad actor in this case this is not
the isp that is the the bad actor and
saying hey you need to go and police all
the traffic and find out how this could
have happened it it puts it puts the isp
technically in a challenging position of
how to
how how do i go and solve this problem
with technology uh and i don't think
that that's the
i don't think that's an easy challenge
so with that i'll
wrap up thank you again for the
opportunity to come and testify with you
guys today i
hope uh
if there are questions i'm happy to take
we do have questions so representative
thank you mr chair thank you for coming
to testify before our committee um
so there are many different layers to
this uh there's browsers there's there's
uh messaging apps that you talked about
uh there's the tor browser i once put in
a bill to have our lot state libraries
run tour notes so
privacy is very uh interesting to me
could you talk a little bit about you
mentioned the header that goes uh that's
like the address on the outside of the
envelope
don't uh cell phone companies and i
think maybe uh it could be that cable
providers do this too don't they inject
something called
like a i think verizon calls it a
connect id
that they inject a number into that
headers so that
sites can identify trace you back to
your
your provider of origin
so i can't speak to verizon or their
business practices
uh so i i don't know on that front uh on
the technical side how to address that
okay i mean it's a pretty common thing
so if you have t-mobile att verizon
you can go in you can opt out of that
marketing id and if you look at
if you look at the data coming across
the you know the wire you can
see that if you're not opted out you'll
have that id injected into it if you opt
out that that is supposed to go away and
i think it does
um
so anyway that's one way that isps can
track you but there are
lots of things that isps don't see i
agree with you on that
um
a customer can use a vpn for instance
right and that would shield a lot of the
data from
the isp at that point wouldn't even know
what your endpoint was
with you is that correct
it would know the end point of the vpn
right so there's still you're still
asking the isp to deliver traffic but
yes obviously vpns are are one of the
the options that are available to
consumers um it's an additional level of
privacy on top of the confidentiality
and integrity provided by docsis which
is the
the cable um again hybrid fiber coax uh
realm uh where we offer
security of that communication vpn adds
another layer to that he brought up tor
that that's
yet another layer on this so consumers
have the ability to
continually obfuscate that technology
and as i mentioned in my testimony uh
dns is also going through an encryption
so we have
something called do which is dns over
https and dot which is dns over tls
two different
methods of encrypting dns traffic
and that's available to consumers as
well
okay i agree you're you're a nerd okay
um i have a technical question too
and that is that i've been watching
these tv ads where a guy's showing up
in everybody's mailbox and while he's
he's pretending like he can read
anything in your mail
and then he
says over his back as he leaves the yard
uh you know they can see everything you
do
and the ad is running on tv i think
it seems like one an hour
and so i'm do you know what the hell
that's all about
i'm sorry sorry i have not seen that ad
uh i i may be in a different tv market
than you well but the reason the reason
i bring it up is because you mentioned
post office and made a connection
between how the postal uh office
you know delivers to your address
your information and all your mail and
then he turns around and says oh by the
way i i can read all this mail anyway
and that's what the ad says would you
believe forget what they're trying to
sell
would you believe would you believe it
i'm seeing this ad and i i have no idea
what it's about representative herbert i
will say that when we talk about
encryption and the confidentiality that
encryption provides um there's actually
two things that happen in
common encryption where there's actually
encryption and some checksums to make
sure that both confidentiality and
integrity of your messages is guaranteed
through delivery
once that's encrypted without having a
key
to one of the the sides of that
encryption if it's if it's shared or
having the recipient key if if you're um
looking at
at reading it without those keys you
cannot see what's inside encrypted
traffic
so the take home here is make sure
all right thank you very much
thank you thank you committee
uh
we'll switch gears here a little bit
jason hennessey
good morning well good morning um
well i'm happy um my name is jason
hennessey i'm here uh representing
myself i'm from the the wonderful town
of amherst
and i'm here to enthusiastically support
hb 1413.
so
in terms of my qualifications i have
over 15 years in the computer industry
about 10 years
as a researcher completing my phd in
computational sciences and statistics
at four years post-doctoral studies in
computing topics at boston university
i've published researchers
published researchers and widely
respected
peer-reviewed venues on related topics
including security privacy and
system-related topics
in modern computing technologies
including a few that have received some
media attention
and so i want to i want to talk a bit
about this bill and i thank you guys for
listening
so
hb 14 hp 1413 basically codifies what
most of us expect when you buy internet
service
you you're not expecting them to capture
every website you go to
you're not expecting them to sell your
location for instance if you have one of
these things
um you know there's evidence that at
least as of a couple of years ago they
were
your location information was being sold
and that's not affected by the location
toggle on your phone because they have
to know where you are based on the
towers
having this information all collected
together remember it's not just you
it's everybody
and so they know you know so it's
possible in these in these databases
that were being sold to whoever had a
credit card i suppose
um
it could be used to do you know for
marketing that's but that's one of the
most
innocuous uses
you know imagine a stalker imagine uh
somebody who's a political rival having
access to all this information
and that was that's just location
privacy
um i want i want to address a little bit
of what i just heard the gentleman
before talking about he talked a lot
about encryption and uh i'll just say
that that is part of the story and there
there's a bit of stuff he left out
so isps like comcast or verizon or
whoever whoever you have
have the ability to track which sites
you go to
even with encryption
it's it's turned out that metadata which
is the data that um talks about who
you're talking to which which sites your
your devices are is talking to
that actually has a large percentage of
the usefulness of even the unencrypted
data
and the fact is that the isps can tell
which sites are going to because there's
a thing called sni built into the
encryption
um which actually reveals which site you
go to so for instance if you go to
pancreaticcancer.com
you know these isps know that
and i want to address representative
ammon's
um question on uh tracking ids
they it turns out that these isps
there's nothing right now that i know of
that prevents them from selling which i
p address you have so whether they
insert an id or not doesn't really
matter if this if this information is on
the open market just like the location
information is
um
it doesn't matter that information is
all is all out there
um in addition to that there's a lot of
peer connections peer-to-peer so like
computer to computer uh that reveal who
you talk to
even in encrypted protocols like signal
um
so
in addition to that
um when they said that you don't know uh
that that the isps don't know what you
watched on netflix the literature has at
least been out there for a decade
that there are these things called side
channels which can look at an encrypted
stream and and figure out with pretty
good certainty what you actually watched
and this isn't just theoretical i
actually had a research project with
high school kids
um who who actually replicated that and
and they were able to get a publication
out of that but the basic the basics
have been there for years
at least a decade
um and so this bill is actually
very very targeted it only targets the
isps and you heard you heard other
people talking about um well you know
there's google and facebook and all
these things well those are optional you
can get by in society without using
facebook or google i try to
um
but the fact is you cannot operate in
the society without having internet
access you know if you don't have a cell
phone if you don't have home internet
you can't do things you can't even do
the legislature stuff right you guys are
on the email all day
um i don't know how you keep up with it
god bless you
but
but you can't do that without getting on
the internet in the first place
so
so this bill is very narrowly targeted
at at what society needs i mean there's
even people who say that internet access
is a human right right and if we can't
get on without being completely
monitored where we go
then you know how are we going to
function in a society when the people
who hold this data
you know start working against our
interests
so
um i want you to be to think about that
also
you know in terms of location
information uh at least as of 2019
all of the major wireless providers were
selling it to intermediaries
and this um and this wasn't just
a theoretical oh they might get
ads or something like that the reason we
figured this out is because there was a
sheriff county sheriff who was using
this to keep tabs on like people like
judges and state police
now thankfully he was caught and
convicted
but
you know how many people like if you can
just get this information like what else
is going on with it and what do we what
do we not know
uh when this practice came to light
uh the the
um mobile company said that they would
end it and at least as as of a year
later they did not there was an article
um i plan to send you guys uh talking
about this
and i i can just say i personally
checked they had one of these one of
these location reselling sites actually
had a site you could go to and look
yourself up
and uh and so i did that and i actually
it i actually saw myself it showed me
just where i was with the location
turned off and everything
take this a step further there was a
somebody figured out that that site had
a bug in it a security bug and you could
look up anybody in the country without
them knowing
so anybody in the world could have just
taken a phone number
plugged it in and tracked that person
now think about think about all the
domestic violence think about burglaries
i mean this is a real issue and this
the the consent that these companies
have is is buried and obscured and i
would argue that it's not informed
consent for instance uh i took a look at
att's privacy policy it was 27 pages
verizon's is 20 pages
and and a lot of times even if you read
the privacy policy it does not spell out
hey we sell all your your browsing and
your
um and your location information you
know it's not very clear even if you
look at it
these these companies thrive on a lack
of informed consent
so hp 1413 simply codifies the common
expectation
that these companies are not doing that
i'll also point out you heard a lot of a
lot of
concern and problems and things like
that i'll point out maine has had this
for years now and the sky has not fallen
last i checked i mean i haven't been
there recently but maybe somebody who's
been to maine can tell me that
uh i i think you can still get internet
i think it's still reasonably priced
the fact is that they won their
challenge at the district level as far
as i know at the federal district level
so this is past constitutional muster
this bill is basically exactly a copy of
that
thankfully plagiarism is legal in laws
um the exceptions that you see in 359 t4
address pretty much all of the problems
uh that
that you've heard about in terms of
getting information
um um you've also heard that
we we should wait we should pause we
should not do this we should wait for
federal legislation
um i'll tell you that the telecom
industry spent 100 over 100 million
dollars in 2016 in order to defeat
uh the federal the federal protections
for privacy and brought in broadband in
2017.
i've i also heard somebody mention that
this would only apply to people in new
hampshire and how are we going to figure
that out well i would argue that comcast
really knows where you are because you
know you don't usually change your home
very often
a lot of this is pretty basic
and i think
that's most of my testimony and so if
anybody has questions i would love to
entertain them
uh representative bartlett did you have
a lot of you are talking over our heads
i have to tell you that
um but one of the questions that came up
from the ag's offices enforcement do you
have any suggestions on how um if this
bill were to pass how it would be
enforced oh thank you representative
bartlett oh i would like to point out
that that there's a that the private
right of action is is good um the the
tcpa actually does this the federal tcpa
where um if you get junk calls in your
phone on your mobile phone or if you get
faxes you can actually take them to
court in in a state court and enforce it
privately i would rec my recommendation
would be that you would be that you guys
um
make a change to basically step up the
penalties to be for the ag's office uh
to be the same as the private penalties
because that would allow that would
allow the ag's office to to sue on
behalf of the consumers
which in a lot of times they have more
technical expertise and resources in
order to do that the consumer protection
law in new hampshire is built around
restitution
so you would have to show
actual economic harm
so i i would argue that the the invasion
of your privacy is a difficult to
quantify harm and that um it is the job
well again that's you know why we we
created the consumer protection act is
created the way it is because it was
just no we we can't we can't do that we
have we have triple damages
but you got to show some damage you got
to sow some economic harm so so i mean
the you know i guess the question is
what
how much do you value the ability of of
a person who's fleeing from her love for
her ex-lover and is being stalked
well
it is criminal but what if no what if
but what if they're using these tools to
find them i mean what's the what's the
private what's the private what's the
what's the value of your privacy and
that's why i would argue that rather
than needing to do what you classically
did which is show show damages um
that i think
as a society i think new hampshire
rights i mean we just passed a
constitutional amendment guarding our
privacy and i would say that in new
hampshire we value it very highly
fair enough representative thank you
chairman um
i was very impressed with the attorney
libman i hope i pronounced that correct
report
um in layman's terms something that i
could understand
would you tell me how
this bill goes above and beyond what the
federal
legislation does
so i i'm not an expert in federal
legislation whenever i look at federal
law it has a million cross references
and i get overwhelmed
but my understanding is that there is
that in 2017 all of the federal privacy
protection acts for broadband were
rolled back after over 100 million
dollars in lobbying
and so
as far as i know there is no federal
protection other than the ftc saying
what you put in your privacy policy you
have to follow
but that's very but again these privacy
policies are 27 pages or 20 pages
sometimes they have like legalese terms
the average person
um i don't believe can
can is going is going to read at a and b
is going to really understand all the
implications
great thank you very much thank you i
okay
good morning good morning chair vice
chair members of the committee um so i'm
going to be recapping a lot of what
people have already said so i'll try and
keep it brief my name is jake lestock
i'm here today on behalf of ctia
we are the trade association that
represents the wireless communications
industry and i'm here in opposition to
this bill this bill would put unworkable
restrictions on how isps or internet
service providers
manage customer information
and would have unintended consequences
that would negatively affect the
businesses and consumers of your state
we'll start off by pointing out that
federal and state law already exists to
protect consumer privacy the federal
trade commission
already has authority over isp privacy
protections
they have for the past 20 years
developed and
enforced an effective privacy framework
that applies to all
players within the internet ecosystem
and as was mentioned before the new
hampshire attorney general also has a
ability to address unfair deceptive
practices with relation to privacy
through your consumer protection laws so
there really is no gap
in privacy protections that the state
needs to address at this time
additionally this legislation is going
to create two sets of rules for various
entities within the internet ecosystem
and we have to remember the internet has
changed a lot a lot of speakers have
discussed this i mean we're not using
stationary computers with one isp now
we're using
multiple devices connecting to multiple
isps accessing content from multiple
edge providers so
imposing these strict opt-in
requirements on isps
is going is not going to protect
consumer privacy online um in fact it's
going to make a lot of confusion for
consumers in your state as
essentially it's going to create these
two levels and they're not going to be
able to determine which is which and
what is being protected and what is not
so uh i think the gentleman from cable
ads mentioned this a lot uh
there is important uh privacy
protections in place through encryption
around i think he mentioned ninety
percent uh of websites are encrypted so
isps are not able to see what you're
viewing on those websites
additionally virtual private networks
were brought up
and when these vpns are in place which
are available to all consumers in your
state isps cannot see
even the domain name that you're
accessing so there are important
tools that are already in place that can
help you with these privacy protections
if you feel the need to have more
additionally
when we're talking about these sweeping
and inflexible opt-in requirements on
isps it does go against or at nearly uh
goes in at odds to nearly every other
piece of legislation or law or framework
that is in place in the country right
now
and the private right of action is going
to put a lot of businesses in new
hampshire at a risk of costly litigation
when it's likely to have little benefit
for consumers in your state and then
finally as was mentioned before there is
a bill that was similar to this that
passed in maine but it is still being
challenged in the courts
so kind of just wrapped up everything
people have said already but
if you have any questions i'm happy to
answer we do have a question yes
representative johnson
thank you for taking my question and um
definitely not some of the learned some
new stuff today thank you
can you tell me approximately how much
money
do
the internet and cable providers make
every year on selling our privacy
because i know it's done
i personally am not able to tell you
first of all i only speak on behalf of
the wireless industry so there is i mean
like i said a very
broad array of wireless players within
the internet ecosystem and i'm not going
to be able to answer uh exactly
the number of that but i'm happy to look
into it if you want me to follow up
afterwards
follow-up question for the question main
choir
um
what
what issues do you seeing in maine that
you so if this bill is following the
main
law that just passed
um so
as i said uh
we filed a lawsuit at the u.s or the
main district court in 2020 and that uh
litigation is still ongoing uh and as
was mentioned before
uh the decision to impose uh
this unique burden on isps alone is that
uh is that
represents discrimination uh on behalf
of the first amendment so those are the
issues that we're seeing
further questioning you say
discrimination for these individuals
what about the right to my privacy and
everybody else in this room
and across the state that have the
have their right to have their privacy
and not have their information sold
yeah thank you for the question
obviously privacy is an important thing
and we believe that privacy issues are
better addressed by a holistic approach
at the federal level as the internet is
inherently interstate and goes across
straight state lines
great thank you very much for your
testimony having no more cards
um
we
let's see um rick fabrizio from the bias
opposed to it and from the overnight we
had three
three in support and two opposed
with that i will close the public
hearing
yes
um
is
life
okay
is
yes
okay
uh sorry about the delay to uh for this
last bill here
i'm sure you found that very interesting
uh
all about the oh don't you turn your you
turn your mic off
okay
there you go
perfect
thank you good morning again i apologize
for the delay
oh that's okay that was that was it was
a fascinating bill to be honest
um
and
today i am here
good morning
mr chairman and honorable members of the
commerce committee
i am suzanne vale and i represent nashua
ward 3 and hillsborough county district
30. i'm here today to present house bill
1422 which is an act that will require
items containing perfluoroalkyl and
pluri polyfloral alco
substances be labeled before being sold
in new hampshire
water supplies have been contaminated
with pfas in new hampshire and currently
there is a factory that continues to use
pfas and manufacturing and makes toxic
releases into the environment on a daily
basis
there are several pfas contamination hot
spots in new hampshire where cancer
clusters are being discovered and folks
who are participating in biomonitoring
studies are beginning to receive results
i'm sorry could you get a little bit
closer oh yeah sure
thank you sorry about that oh yeah
to work okay
there are several pfas contamination hot
spots in new hampshire where cancer
clusters are being discovered people who
are participating in fire monitoring
studies are beginning to receive the
results
and they are very difficult to interpret
if it were you you would want you would
be glad to be in the study
you would want to stop using pfas
chemicals and you would want to know
where they are and if you have them in
your life unknowingly
if you follow the guidance that is
available you know that you have to
clean your home very carefully test and
filter your water and decrease the
presence of pfas in your life in any way
that you can
we have in new hampshire passed
legislation to set max contamination
levels to extend the statute of
limitations to prove injury
with pfas
to
test wells and we have instituted an
array of measures that have raised
awareness and put the harmed in a better
position
but as community members some of us have
come together to educate one another
about how to decrease
our exposure to pfas
you have an information sheet that is a
print out of pfas new hampshire fact
sheet as well as an faq
that goes with it and the cinco
infographic is a result of a
non-legislative act where myself and
another legislator set out to find
someone to help us teach people what
a committee formed involving researchers
at dartmouth college new hampshire
health and human services des
and cdc community representatives and
the fact sheet is the result of let's
say about 18 months worth of work maybe
two years
it is a pdf online and it is hosted at
the dartmouth medical school website it
is updated
on i think it's a six-month basis
and i have sent that to you in an email
so that you would have the dynamic
document where you can click through
and get to the resources
at the end of the last year i looked at
all of our legislation and i visited
saferstates.org
website to see how new hampshire is
doing in terms of his striving to be a
safer state
in terms of pfas
and i was happy to see that we are
considered to be a safer state and that
our efforts have been listed there and
including
this effort which goes into the future
and the efforts of other states to try
to combat the same problem
there are labeling bills in other
legislature
in the country and in fact
almost all of
the efforts in legislating and educating
about pfas have been designed to empower
people so that they can live their life
with as little
mystery and as many choices as they can
possibly make
so when i wrote the bill
it's taken from a michigan bill that
contains
the most comprehensive structure that i
could find to serve as a basis
i spoke at length with a representative
who filed a short form bill in vermont
and that's where you make a statement of
a bill that you would like to
study and if the committee decides to
accept it they work on it and they come
up with a bill if they think it's a
feasible idea
he didn't think his bill was going
anywhere
and i'm not sure about some of the other
bills
this is a very challenging bill
and it has some flaws
and but what it tries to do is to tell a
manufacturer and distributor to label
products to be sold in new hampshire
that contain pfas as such
it is just a warning that simply says
contains pfas and packaging or item and
has been linked which has been linked to
cancer major illness and reproductive
harm
i've included in your also in your info
packet a couple examples of labels that
could be applied after the fact
on stock that people already have and
i'm thinking in my mind as i'm writing
this bill that someone wants to buy a
set of pots and pans and they go into
the store and they want to look at the
label and see does this non-stick
pan was it manufactured with pfas or not
is it going to raise my
exposure to pfast when i'm cooking
so
back to the bill
i think i heard the word teflon yes
we're talking about teflon and gore-tex
and anything that
has waterproof coating we're talking
about the inside of food packaging where
it's slick and nothing sticks to it
we're talking about glide
dental floss we're talking about
waterproof eyeliner
and we're talking about a lot of
different
items that
some of the things are
listed and resources that i've sent in
your email and also what you have there
in front of you
so
i have sent you a few resources
including informations
in your email on the recent findings on
the cancer cluster
study that's going on at dhhs
for people who are in the vicinity of
the saint-gobain
performance plastics in merrimack if you
are unable to access this file let me
know it's a big file so i couldn't email
it to you i had to put it on a cloud
somewhere and then supposedly you're
going to be able to view it
through your microsoft exchange
so
so that's where that is for you
but as again i said the bill intends to
empower new hampshire families to have a
modicum of control over bodily
contamination it is known that all of us
have pfas in our blood it is thought to
be found in the blood of creatures all
over the world
in places where these chemicals were
never used or created including at the
north pole
and
examine the bill in light of the
foregoing facts and understand that it
is an adaptation there are known
barriers to this
process
i know one of them is interstate
commerce laws which i know very very
little about
the bill itself
when it was adapted through ols
it did the
definition of department and i want to
say that would be
it doesn't refer to des and so the
fiscal note is rather irrelevant
because it's not des that would be the
department
in the bill that i adapted this from
the department was described as
licensing and regulatory affairs and i
asked for the
new hampshire complement to that to be
listed as the draft month i didn't get i
didn't get the fiscal note or the whole
bill back until just before christmas so
um
unfortunately there were a lot of things
that need to be addressed in the bill
but i appreciate the opportunity to
present it and i welcome any questions
i will do my best to answer them and
thank you mr chairman
okay
any questions from the committee yes
representative burroughs
yes thank you for taking my question
thank you mr chair um my question is
this given the difficulty of enforcing
this and the cost to enforce it you know
there must be thousands of products that
have this um
i'm wondering first of all
would this
maybe be a good idea to follow the gmo
labeling which is based on the usda
and um and secondly maybe it makes more
sense to for this to be voluntary given
that there are a lot of consumers that
don't want this chemical in their
products i certainly don't and just like
gmos we seek out
products that have the no gmo labels
might we do the same thing with pfas and
it would be a good marketing tool for
companies
honestly i think that's extremely
innovative and that's why i bring this
bill to this committee because i hope to
have that kind of expertise i think if
it could be a voluntary thing and there
were no fines involved that it would be
a far better bill
and i also agree that people want to
show you that they're not going to
poison you and people are really
becoming aware of the extent of this
problem
so did i answer your question thoroughly
you did thank you so much thank you
okay representative abel's first
uh thank you thank you so much for uh
testifying for introducing the bill
i noticed in one of the uh uh
sets of material that we were
uh sent around
uh that there is an example of
uh of a label that says that indicates
that cal the state of california has
decided a particular product
might
contain some
particular dangerous materials and it
reminds me that we had it we've had
bills in the past
where
there were substances in furniture and
so forth and in one case
there was a decision to say that if the
state of california had declared
that
new hampshire would use that as its as
its way of of regulating it uh figuring
that that's a big market we're a tiny
market
i'm just i'm con my question my question
is how would how could we
do labeling so that a manufacturer
didn't have to have 50 different labels
for each state who wanted it a different
way but we could make it as easy for
them
to do it and what your thoughts are on
that and perhaps in amending this bill
in some way
thank you for the question
representative abel i would be extremely
open to having amendments to the bill
that would include that type of
to me it seems to be a very very
solid idea that
and i i don't know if we would do that
but i would imagine that we would say if
it's labeled for california it works
here but i'm not sure exactly how we
would do that
and i think if the label meets the
requirements which are very simple
um in terms of what's in the bill then
it fits it does not have to be new
hampshire specific
i'm not sure how we would get there from
representative johnson
thank you thank you for taking my
question
so
do you i know that you sent us this
information
and you listed some um products that
have
pfas in it um we heard a bill earlier
um
this session
and there is a lot more items than what
you listed and i've got the list here
electronics alternative energy
aerospace and defense automotive
products healthcare products
semiconductors
pharmaceuticals
there are so much more
than what you have indicated
and
so my question is
i really think that how do we
get all these manufacturers from all
these different industries
for just new hampshire and and
because new hampshire is new hampshire
we're not california
and i worry about new hampshire i don't
thank you for the question i'm having a
little difficulty parsing the question
well they will leave it as a would you
believe
okay thank you
there are literally hundreds and
probably thousands and thousands of
things that contain pfas and i think we
need to start but i do think that we
have to remember that we are in a global
market almost all of the time and that
when things are manufactured all kinds
of labels are put on them and the
manufacturers seem to be able to know
where they can sell the items and what
fair enough uh
thank you
uh i'm going to kind of play devil's
advocate
say this bill did go through and pass
and
virtually everything we see
touch
feel
and whatever has a label on it now
i have a cell phone just like
virtually 100 of everybody else in this
room it has a label on it
what do we do with it
and
what
what is that going to mean to me except
it's got a label on it
could you kind of help me out with that
please thank you
you're going to have a choice i want i'm
just
representative
you you will have a choice about what
you
want to buy
you're going to want to buy the thing
that has the lowest amount of risk for
you
and if it's an item that contains pfas
you're going to want to make sure that i
mean a cell phone i would not be so
worried about i would be more worried
about food packaging
and
like frozen dinners that type of thing
but in terms of like like a stable item
that's standing you know
it's not decomposing it's not going into
landfill it's not touching something
that you're going to eat it's not makeup
going into your eye
you know we have to look at the kinds of
objects that you're looking at to decide
where the safety lies for you
right so you're saying you we need to
pick out those items that are really
consumable or things that we're going to
be
have a high
probability of getting coming in contact
with the pfas product
so you don't expect to put a big giant
label on a car
a new car no
no no there's a lot of um chips and a
lot of pfas in a car i'm sure of it yeah
but you would have the parts of them
you would want it on your pots and pans
where you're going to be at the stove
and you know that the coatings on pans
wear out and you know you can only
imagine i bet some of it goes in your
dishwasher and some of it goes down the
drain but some of it you eat so
and that's tough so when you buy your
pots and pans you want to know can i
have non-stick or is it totally out do i
turn to wax paper now instead of to the
insides of these boxes that are coated
with plastic that we'll never get rid of
that's going to stand the test of time
and be gone long after man is here
no we we want to just do what we can
today to make it a longer and better
life for the people who are here
representative bartlett
thank you mr chair
thanks for bringing this bill you know
you know there's a lot of issues with it
but one of the things i think that's
been really really valuable um through
this exercise would you believe that i
think that i mean until two weeks ago i
didn't know that that
dental floss had pfas in it and that's
going to go right into my bloodstream so
i think the education
value for this bill is tremendous
so don't
don't be discouraged if we kill it but i
think that
that
all of this whether we're in favor of
regulation or not
or labeling or not
are learning
about what what pfas is doing um and i
think that the conversation will
continue
thank you so much representative i
really appreciate that and that is
really why we're here i mean
we know that the bill has flaws and we
know that it's an attempt and we know
that i mean it really has some flaws
but i would love it if you if if the
committee fell in love with the bill and
there's something about it that could
just be a single thing that would help
but i really think that
you know when i come into a committee
this i think is my fourth time
presenting a bill that's related to pfas
and i don't know if that committee knows
about pfas and what they know about it
but by the time you get over to the
senate you're talking with people is the
word is getting around and that you
don't have to start at the beginning of
the story anymore and so i'm really
grateful that you already have some
experience under your belt and that
you're here looking out for consumers in
new hampshire
so thank you
i think this committee gets a how
insidious it is it's
everywhere so
great thank you very much
chair we'll call on uh representative
wendy chase
thank you and good oh noah good
afternoon pull the mic close this okay
how's that you're gonna we'll learn when
we get on the house floor these mics are
really good to be close to
okay
thank you and good afternoon chairman
hunt and honorable members of the
commerce committee my name is
representative wendy chase and i live in
rollinsford and i represent stratford
county district 18 which is rollinsford
and somersworth i am a co-sponsor and i
strongly support
hb
14-22
and as it was says we do know that there
are a lot of flaws that needs work but
the thing is the awareness and to get
the word out that this is something
that's put into our bodies all the time
and we should have that option
of at least being educated and aware
i did give a testimony i'm not going to
go through everything because you a lot
of it is stats
i also sent you some documents via the
little portal that we have i wasn't able
to print those out but they are
interesting especially i'm part of the
peas study for pfast i live in the
seacoast i received my test results back
without any real
explanation as to what they meant my
levels are high but what the heck what
does that mean
how did this happen so there's um i i
unfortunately could not print it out so
i'm hoping that you will take the time
to just look at that and understand
what's given back to
the residents that are in the study
without any
knowledge of what does it mean do i tell
my doctor am i supposed to be aware of
things now what what is this health risk
and and how did it happen that's why we
want to be able to uh to let people know
so i am very proud to share that my
family has lived in new hampshire for 11
generations and we've resided on the
seacoast for the past 70 years
we have a severe pfas issue here in new
hampshire and throughout the state
and i do feel very strongly that our
residents have the right to and deserve
to know where pfas is found in the
products that we use daily
so with the warning labels again it
could be something very basic but it's
just so that when you pick something up
like the gmo and you say oh this
contains gmo i don't really want to use
it what do i have an alternative that's
what we're trying to
accomplish or be
excuse me aware of
so i won't tell you what pfas is but it
is in here in since 1960 the fda has
authorized several broad classes of pfas
for use in food containers substance due
to
the non-stick and grease oil
so sorry
and the water resistant properties as we
were just talking about
so they have some of these been deemed
that they're not harmful but
we know that
over the years this does create problems
in our our blood systems so to ensure
the food contact substance are safe for
the intended use the fda has conducted a
rigorous view of scientific data prior
to the authorization for market entry
this includes viewing the data's
migration of the food contact substance
into the food
expected consumer exposure to the food
context substance and
excuse me from this
the other uses in food and potential
health impacts from the exposure
p fats that are authorized
for use in contact with the food
generally fall in these application
categories and i'm really basically
talking about the food and what we are
ingesting so we know the non-stick
cookware
gaskets and o-rings that are used in
food processing equipment
pfest may be used in the resin
in forming a certain parts of the food
processing equipment that requires a
durable
chemical invisible i'm so sorry i need
processing aids may be used for
food contents
and the polymer what it does is it
reduces the buildup on the manufacturing
equipment
so again even though
it may not be right in our food it is in
it's being used in the machinery that is
processing our foods so here's a little
bit more that's added it's in
paper bags and paper board it's in used
as a grease non-proof
agent for wrappers microwave popcorns
it's in pet food bags
and this gets leaked into our
land it gets leaked into the water and
also exposed into the air
so even though the recent efforts to
remove certain p-fats from
commerce
have reduced the likelihood of exposure
some household products and indoor air
or dust
it's been a long morning thank you
so some of these products in
indoor air and dust may still contain
pfest so even though we're trying to get
this squared away it is still found as i
mentioned in the beginning of my
testimony i did grow up on the sea coast
hampton's north beach to be exact and
there are so many documented pfest
areas of contamination northampton and
parts of portsmouth greenland have some
of the highest pediatric clusters in new
england my daughter
first born was diagnosed in 1987 with
ewing sarcoma at the age of two
ewings is a rare bone cancer and it's
childhood cancer but it is one of the
highest known cancers caused by pfast
so was it with the water that i drank
growing up the playing fields that i
played in in my youth was it the local
eggs the vegetables or the meats that i
consumed that would have caused my child
to develop such a rare cancer and i'm
not saying that pfast is the cause of
that but it really gives me the food for
thought yikes i live in an area with a
cancer cluster this is a number one
pediatric cancer and my baby
was diagnosed at two years old
something's not right
so i also sent as i said my pfas study
results which i would like you to take a
look at if you can because if you can
decipher it please get in touch with me
and let me know i have been in touch
with the pfas study group
explained that i really felt
i'm not given the information i needed
and what are you doing to try to help
people understand do we talk to our
doctors what are we supposed to do once
we get these results
very very bad vague information and i
can send you those replies too if
anyone's urge
wants to know
so anyway the bottom line is i don't
know we all i know i have high levels of
pfas i don't know where they came from i
don't know what that causes in
my health
i'm not the only one it's something that
i really
hope that you consider to think about
amend whatever we have to do to work on
this to be able to let the public know
what is actually in the products that
they're using
and let them make the choice as to what
they want to buy and what they don't
want to buy
that's it i want to thank you so much
for the water i want to thank you for
the time
and if there are any questions i'd be
happy to ask
the answer
representative thank you mr chair thank
you for taking my question
who is ultimately responsible for all
the pfas that's in
our waters our lands in the air
all over the world that's a really tough
it i don't know really where it started
but it um
3m
is a big contributor
it's in gore-tex it's it's in the teflon
pans i mean they're the ads of to help
the housewives with this great new pan
that's a non-stick and that was way back
in the early 50s this has been around a
long time it's also
in
you know fertilizer so we know that our
animals are getting affected as well so
i can't tell you who it's everywhere and
it's all over the world
just to follow up for the question main
question would you believe it's the
chemical companies oh yes i understand
that i'm sorry i thought you were asking
representing greece
thank you representative for taking our
questions i think the next bill needs to
be we need to ban the periodic table
um
more realistically is are there what
kind of manufacturing may be down in
your area that perhaps the residues or
the byproducts of manufacturing
may be
questionably dumped into the water we
had another representative sponsor bill
and there was some manufacturing in his
his district it had been proven that
they were dumping
pfas or i think is pfas actually
into the water supply
in his district
is there is there any manufacturing of
such like in your district as well that
we can
narrow that narrow the look into because
to say it's it's everywhere so we need
to ban all chemicals
uh is is
not not even possible but if we can find
and and and specify
that it's coming from here and if
they're doing something illegally or if
they're doing something
negligently or whatever that's a whole
different issue
entirely than trying to slap a label on
every single product
so thank you for your question and yes
and also we're not trying to ban
chemicals that's not what we're trying
to do we're trying to just we need them
we're looking to help the consumer
understand what they're putting in their
body as we do with other things yes
absolutely 100 percent peas air force
base that's where our area of the sea
coast has had the most problem in that
um i mean it's been being looked at
things have been stopped it's a lot of
the foam that is used on the airplanes
to put fires out and things so what i
would forget what exactly that foam is
called
and it thank you and what's happened is
it's been used for years and years and
years my dad was stationed there and and
it's gotten into the land it's gotten
into our water it's gotten into our
landfills
it gets into our fish it gets into our
oceans but the other thing is we have
coakley landfill which is a superfund
spot so when the epa came in to clean
that up
what they did is they put a cap over it
well that
great for a little bit but it it's still
seeping underneath so all of what we're
finding with that cancer cluster i was
telling you in the seacoast area
is that's that superfund is still
leaking and it's leaking from underneath
the cap
and it's getting into the waterways of
the the developments and the people's
houses and homes and wells in that area
so no we don't have a
saint-gobain but we have peas air force
base a lot of
excuse me again that's where a lot of
that research is coming from from the
peas that i talked about i should have
said what it was
because the water is very contaminated
people are sick
childhood learning center there you know
these are kids that are being exposed
and drinking that water for years this
has been going on for years
so that's where the level in the testing
representative
yes thank you representative for taking
my question and i hope you don't mind if
i get a little personal because i know
you've been public about that public
about this um
does
does the medical community in new
hampshire believe that your daughter's
death um i i forget what age she was
when she died was in any way related to
pfas
thank you for the
question that's again very difficult
because there's no way of really telling
how she developed that cancer i was
actually just telling representative
vale i am in a pediatric
long-term survivor study right now
that's being done through
baylor college and also with dartmouth
hitchcock so what i'll be doing next is
sending out some of erin's baby teeth
and they're taking all of this
information and trying to see what was
it in the dna what happened
back then can we get a little bit better
idea of how
a two-year-old would end up with an
enormous
bone
growing tumor
so no i've even asked her oncologist and
i've asked her orthopedic oncologists
too
geez could pfest have been there and and
it always brings me they'll talk about
the the wolburn the woburn area
that was years ago but remember all the
kids the big cluster so yeah nobody can
say yes or no but it's definitely you
know it makes you think well wait a
minute so i cannot answer what caused
her
cancer
i just
have a feeling it could have definitely
been a good part of it
thank you so much okay
yes you have to pull pull it pretty
close to you
there can you hear me closer
believe it or not
see how close i am okay so um
you know i think
i think the pfos is is tragic my husband
works for the department of
environmental services so i get to hear
pretty regularly
about what's going on at the state level
and the invest investigations into the
various
areas and the difficulty that they're
having meeting the requirements or even
identifying
the potential exposures
but my concern with this particular bill
is in the enforcement
um
because as i read the enforcement which
obviously if we're gonna if we're gonna
be able to make progress here we have to
be able to hold people accountable and i
think labeling is a great idea
um but there are some things in the
enforcement that i really don't
understand like why you might have gone
in that direction because
some of it is is related to holding a
person accountable instead of an
organization or a manufacturer or
um so so i i was questioning that um i
see that there's civil fines but
if this is i'm wondering if there's a a
criminal
or consumer protection angle that should
be addressed and the other thing i
noticed was the um
that it would be done at a county level
but because pfas is so extensive it's
got to cross county lines it's got
across state lines it's got to cross
international borders so
i i'm
i don't know how a county prosecutor or
attorney general could hold
someone accountable i think
maybe it should be at a higher level i
don't know i'm just wondering where
the enforcement component of the bill
came from
thank you for your question and so are
we no actually
what um
as representative vale had said this was
based off of michigan who has a there's
a senator who has put a bill in i think
about four years ago i did talk to her
about it it's kind of just in a
stalemate right now so
we
use that as the concept of what the bill
should be and both of us yes we've
talked a lot on this and we've talked
to represent
i'm sorry senator hassan's office we've
had talks
zoom calls trying to just figure this
out because we know this is not just a
state
issue so we wanted to also in involve
our federal
representatives as well and see what's
going on at the federal level and try to
figure this out and also as
representative bale said even with
vermont which is the other state that we
know that's trying to do something with
labeling everything's kind of at a
standstill right now and this is why we
it's awareness we really want to bring
this forward we'd like to know
what needs to be done you're absolutely
right it's hard and we sat and scratched
our heads like well how are we going to
penalize this one person and what about
things that are already on the shelves
if the law were to go into effect so
i'm i'm going to say it this is a food
for thought this is something that i'm
hoping others will join on board with us
and we'll really pick this up when we
rewrite it we amend it whatever we do
it's the awareness that this seems to be
in our minds the next step of letting
consumers understand what's going on and
not having it in the isolated areas of
merrimack and their water or the
seacoast but it's everywhere maine
they're asking people not to eat the
deer they kill they're worried about the
um the fish that are being caught it's
huge it's getting bigger it's there it's
the awareness and we just want to be one
of the first to really do something
great thank you very much for your
testimony
uh one more card left kirsten koch from
bia
yes we have made it into the afternoon
so good afternoon mr chairman and
members of the committee my name is
kirsten koch and i'm the director of
public policy for the business and
industry association also known as bia
i'm here today to express ba's
opposition to house bill 14-22
ba fully acknowledges concerns
surrounding the contamination of
perforated chemicals in new hampshire's
natural resources
but today my testimony will address the
feasibility of implementing this bill at
the state level in the business
community
baa believes the house bill 1422 would
be impossibly burdensome for
manufacturers and retailers to implement
into practice
this mandate would affect businesses in
nearly every single industry
this bill is even going so far as to
attempt to regulate commerce at a state
uh regional national and international
level
house bill 1422 requires the state to
evaluate and regulate nearly every
product manufactured for sale in new
hampshire
in addition to identifying violations
and enforcing fines
this bill would be especially damaging
for new hampshire small businesses
because they do not have the resources
to
monitor and label the sale of every
otherwise legal product in new hampshire
furthermore
multi-state businesses need uniformity
and law to effectively ensure their
ability to consistently apply
so in conclusion bia respectfully
requests this committee to vote for a
motion of inexpedient to legislate
this policy should be addressed at a
federal level and the burden this bill
creates should not fall on local
businesses nor the new hampshire
department of environmental services so
i thank you for your consideration of
our position on this legislation and i
would gladly try to answer any questions
representative abel
yes thank you
thank you so much for for uh coming and
testifying um
based on an earlier bill we heard you
may not have been here then
and this one that also
uh talks about
the possibility of handling things on a
on a federal level or an estate level i
i just wonder if
if if you or the bia has a has a
viewpoint on what's appropriate
to be done at a state level
when when there's an issue
where
regulation could be done on on
on both the federal and the state level
i'm just trying to get a sense of what
is appropriate for a state to try to do
and what is best for the federal
government to regulate
thank you so much for your question
representative we believe this policy
should be addressed at the federal level
multi-state businesses need their
uniformity and
you know be incredibly difficult if not
impossible for the state to regulate
every single product that comes into new
hampshire for sale i mean this bill even
addresses uh products that are sold over
the internet and you think about amazon
and how popular that is today i just it
would be impossible for the state to
address that so that's why we believe
that this policy would be best addressed
at the federal level
representative bartlett
do you even have this on your radar
as an issue that's affecting new
hampshire residents
consumers
thank you for your question
representative absolutely pfas is one of
our highest priorities and we fully
acknowledge the concerns surrounding
pfas and and i commend you know the
prime sponsor and the co-sponsors for
addressing uh this topic and bringing
further question
thanks i just want to follow up um a
little bit if it is a top priority
could you give us an idea of what
the discussions are
and any kind of other than just saying
it's a federal problem
any kind of solution that might be
proposed or discussed with your members
sure thank you representative
we believe that pfas
policies and regulations should be set
on science-based policy and
generally you know this type of policy
is best set at the epa on the federal
level but we're just looking for
science-based policy and not just
arbitrary measures so our concern is
just maintaining that science-based
policy
representative fargo
yes and thank you for your testimony um
yeah
while i agree that this should be
addressed at a federal level
i would want to know why you would say
that the burden isn't the responsibility
of the new hampshire department of
environmental services
thank you for your question well it
would be their burden um and we don't
think it's it's reasonable or realistic
for
this burden to belong to just the depart
the new hampshire des we believe this
issue is much larger
than maybe even something that could
handle it should be addressed at the
federal level
something this bill is missing
especially in the fiscal note is that it
doesn't address
um the cost for lab testing and what it
would take to evaluate and identify you
know thousands of products that are for
sale in new hampshire and we just don't
think they have the staff the resources
to possibly even carry out what this
bill would require
for the question you may inquire it does
for the question yep
so my question then is if you don't feel
if you if you
what is the purpose of the develop
department of environmental services if
not to address
chemicals that are
polluting our environment i'm
you know my husband works for the
department of environmental services so
i'm finding this a little bit of a
stretch for me
sure thank you for your question
representative uh let me clarify uh we
absolutely believe in the capabilities
of
des here in new hampshire
we just think that what this bill
requires is so large and so costly that
okay great thank you very much thank you
i have no more cards um
the
sign in sheet was blank
and
uh or the overnight we got
seven in support into an opposition
and with that i will close the public
hearing
okay
um
so
he implied that some states allowed this
or something did he
think that that was true or something
in his testimony
i don't see how it could i mean perhaps
the state law in another state allows
more flexibility but it still would be
preempted by federal law so
right
so do we have what what do we have now
for short-term policies do we have
anything now
we have we do have a company that does
offer short-term policies there's just
one though
so there aren't very many out there and
what what's the need because i remember
one time it was like ten thousand
the benefits are very limited um i
couldn't tell you what the benefits in
the policy that's being sold in new
hampshire at the moment i could get back
to you but a lot of people do buy these
policies without understanding they're
as limited as they are
even things like um
while the new hampshire insurance
mandates apply to these policies there
they can do pre-existing condition
exclusion so
virtually anything that would have a
state mandate would they could put in a
pre-existing conclusion
condition and not cover that services
for that type of thing
so
in general um there have been some
national reports put out around
short-term policies and some of the
consumer dissatisfaction with them um
but uh but new hampshire's experience is
pretty limited
do you get complaints for people once
they realize what they bought i'm not
but it's only six months now right in
our our that policy with the
right the nature of the policy we have
i believe that's true yeah i
um yes i think it's six months with one
renewal
six months with one renewal so you could
technically get a whole year
yeah
you just shovel yeah but here a lot of
okay
all right john can i ask tyler questions
can i ask tyler
um
tyler
um thank you for being here
we've talked many times in the past
about how
um destabilizing the the
insurance
policies could impact premiums and cause
overall premiums to go up in the state
because of the inability to have the
stability that we need and we've had
this conversation countless times over
the last couple years how do you think
this would impact
premiums in the long term
yeah so your question your question is
very loaded and right on i mean to the
extent you could create an opportunity
for healthier people
to leave the the heavier that the more
regulated market go into something like
a short-term policy or an hp something
that has a premium that that would
benefit them being healthy you draw
those healthy people out of the larger
market and then and then you're left
with sicker people who pay more in terms
of their premiums the
in this case because the federal law has
certain requirements um it would preempt
any sort of state flexibility so while
you could have some seepage some leakage
from the regulated market in terms of
healthy people um it would be less
though than if those healthy people had
a more permanent
option um in the short-term policy arena
you know when we when we passed senate
bill 7-eleven so paul and i are probably
the only ones in the room who remember
all that
and
and uh everybody else i think is
missed out on that fun
um so we actually passed you know the
affordable care act long before
then it actually became federal law
and
and the the whole debate around that
original bill was
it was what was it what was the company
called was it pine tree or pine uh
pineapple or
it was someone that they were very
golden rule that's right golden rule
that's it golden rule
and and the rule the goal the golden
rule was as soon as you made a claim
you got cancelled
so
the policies were great and as long as
you never made a claim right but as soon
as you made a claim is you were they
somehow
just non-renewed you
and uh and that and that really is what
how we got into passing community rating
in the first place
so
seeming you know assuming in this case
you know these these
policies we have now these short-term
policies
which you know that
they violate you know you know they they
probably have caps right do they have
we know the one product we have in this
market what the cap is
we don't know we apologize uh yeah
okay
i'd be interested to know what the one
product we have do do you know the camp
you know paul
yeah
who who's the one company that is
selling
there's one company
right
well i'd be interested to know some of
the details on it i think
before we kill this bill that i think we
should at least know what what's out
there
and what is there i mean obviously
you're
you would argue that you would go cobra
but you know cobra is hugely expensive
when you're paying the employer portion
you know you're playing the poison so i
assume these these short-term policies
are fairly inexpensive
um
they tend to be
less expensive but not the benefits are
not proportional so the proportional the
benefits would be much weaker versus the
lower cost well
the benefits meaning that they they
so what's the benefit of putting this
off
i would like to know if we're going to
make a case for why we're not going to
pass this bill
i think we need to be able to tell
people what's what is available what is
that that short form policy is
so at least we can articulate that and
know what know exactly
what is going on with the marketplace
another another question from a consumer
protection kind of perspective you know
and
i mean sadly because
if you have one of these short-term
policies
and people aren't educated i mean like
my husband got cancer out of the blue we
didn't he was never sick at the end of
his life it was just a freak thing and
next thing you know we're we're in
trouble
and and
are there any safeguards for people who
i would think in some in a case like
that they'd probably consider it a
pre-existing
exclusion i mean that yeah i mean the
safeguards typically are when you lose
your insurance coverage you have access
to the marketplace the exchange and um
and that's guaranteed issue and normally
you know that's really the big
difference now even before past 7-eleven
or even when the affordable care act was
first you know was that that
we now have a very active thriving
marketplace for individuals
subsidized by all of us
so
so so the premiums are not as bad as
they could be
so it's uh and
so theoretically yeah where it basically
drives people into the marketplace
which is what you you know if you're if
your employer or whatever you're not
gonna you would normally would not
hold out for your next employer if you
were changing jobs you would just go
into the marketplace
so you really
wouldn't even buy one of these
short-term policies anyways there's not
as much demand for it for sure i would
think that i would think now the
marketplace is fine
so um
for you
you guys uh representation grayson who
are kind of
new to all of this um are you following
what we're talking about in terms of
the the difficulties of this short you
know what he the bill which was to take
the short-term policy and try to make it
available which clearly violates federal
law but uh but in terms of you know what
what people need to know is that yes
you're supposed to go to the marketplace
and get an individual policy
you guys comfortable with that you
understand that yes i'm generally aware
of this uh mr chairman although i
wouldn't want to be tested on it right
now
so how are you leaning right now i mean
what's up
how are you leaning
well i mean i i wouldn't pass this bill
no i would never pass the bill the
question is you know whether interim
study so we can work you know talk about
it or learn about it but i before i'd
rather i'd rather
let's wait just that's late to learn
about what the policy is
and then before we decide to say
something okay yes holly
why don't you come forward you have to
you have to have a mic
but i think we're i think we're online i
for the record holly stevens i represent
nami i did a little bit of research
while we were i was back there just kind
of googling okay the one plan in new
hampshire
or the one company is independence
american insurance company independence
a member of the ihc group whatever that
is
independent america american
insurance company insurance company
never heard of them they've got a number
of different plans depending on
deductible amount and out-of-pocket
amounts
but the one um important thing that i
think is worth noting is that
it says for every single plan that is
listed um
for me i put in my birth date and that
i'm a non-smoker and that i'm a female
um there is
no coverage for outpatient prescription
drugs
for any of their plans
it has no drug plans no drug plan at all
so the one provider in our state does
not provide any coverage for
prescription
medications
that could be somebody who would want
that plan you know i mean if you're
young i mean we're assuming that most
people who take these are young people
so i mean that they might not want a
drug plan
but does it say anything about the
premiums what the hell
yes depending on the deductible amount
like there's one where there's a
deductible of ten thousand dollars
um the
uh
premium is 179.
but i can't tell from here though what
benefits are covered what they actually
cover right i can't tell if they cover
mental health or substance use or
maternity or anything like that i'm
assume all those wonderful things are
not being covered i would assume that as
well
we're talking you were talking about a
truly catastrophic type plan
so i just offered that to you chairman
um because i found it online
right
great
if young people are buying these
policies is that what's happening yeah
well that that's who i always thought it
was yeah
well we should force them into a system
where they subsidize us old people right
that's that's that is the current that
is the current law yeah the current law
is really built around the idea i was
it was tongue-in-cheek but yes
there is no doubt that uh
the whole point of community rating
was that and
and right from the day one for the
original battle was the age banding
and actually when we tried and the age
banding now is what three and three
point five and ones and we did have
three and a half to one three and a half
to one
so i when we
i always said when when we tried to
revisited the non-group market
and um we at the individual market we we
actually
removed age banning altogether we
actually brought it back this was under
benson
and
and i always said the mistake i made at
the time
was that i just removed all age banding
and i should have left in some age
banding because we absolutely had
individuals that came in and said all of
a sudden they were they were paying you
know outrageous amount of premium
and uh it was because they were
you know the upper end
because once you get 65 your your
medicare right so so if you were 60
years old
the premium was was i think in this case
i think it was like 12
to 1.
it was that that huge of a band
and so i always said the mistake was i
should have made it six to one
and that that maybe it wouldn't have
been as bad
um and we might not have
end up
so yes the idea is that you now it's
interesting because
i remember new york they had no age
banding
there was one premium for everybody
so yeah in that case young people were
really
subsidizing
the old people
but uh the age banding you know
obviously was we we did at that time i
think we were four to one three to one
was it i think it was three to one
wasn't it paul i think it was originally
three to one
and that and the idea was that we would
uh at least
give some
but yes it's i have no doubt in my mind
that that the nature of insurance in
general and and the best the only reason
you can call health insurance insurance
at all
is that work that we're
assuming that uh
younger
healthier people
are going to
pay the premium because they think they
should have insurance
everybody else
so i have some younger friends they like
to go rock climbing and they're very
healthy right so right if i were them
i'd be worried about falling and
breaking a leg or maybe getting cancer
but i wouldn't be worrying about you
know they're very fit
getting diabetes or something like that
right so right having them
have options i think is a good thing
it would be nice but we can't
in the real world
but let me say the affordable care act
so
there is an option for catastrophic
coverage onto the aca
why call the catastrophic is the high
deductible that's what's catastrophic to
me it is
is that where you're going yeah it is
it's okay
it's not really catastrophic it just
means it means you're going to pay all
out a pocket
until you you know
ten thousand dollars i mean i've never
that's that's huge
i mean i know
as a as in a small group as an employer
with small group i think the highest you
know i i think i'm paying now it's
the height is 6 500
so the first 6 500
is is
but you know the prem the premium is
right
yeah so
okay so see what you can find out i'd be
interested in how many people were
buying it
what's you know whatever you can find on
it yeah we don't have the number of
people who are buying it so not
something that's generally reported oh
you don't know you don't know
no no we don't but don't don't you guys
have to audit this company on a regular
basis um they may submit information
through
um
well a company may submit information
that is fairly basic
part of what we consider a survey but
it's uh
we're pretty hands off with the
assuming because there aren't too many
of them
and there's not a lot of regulatory
i need
more
info
on current company okay
all right
next
relative requiring insurance coverage
for vaccinations devices medications
authorized for emergency use by the
united states food and drug
administration
okay yeah so this one
did we have any evidence that that
anybody's been rejected or how do we
know
that i think you sent out sent us out
the question is is actually has there
been a situation where somebody was
refused
um
okay
i mean we could interim study it just so
in case
something did come up
but passing it just for the sake of
passing it i i
don't know do somebody feel that we
should do that
i like to keep less clutter in our
statutes
the the
the issue that's brought to mind uh the
concern of of representative gay
uh is to ensure that
insurance companies are are covering
any injuries that are caused by
vaccines
and medicines that are authorized for
use by the fda under emergency use
authorization
okay right um there's a if there is a
chance or
there's a perceived threat that an
insurance company would not cover those
injuries you weren't taking that uh
you know as being uh on label or you
take an experimental vaccine yeah
experience okay something like that so
an insurance company may not cover those
expenses because it was experimental
ensuring making sure that people are
covered by those types of injuries
and that was one of the one of the
statements that came out during the
original hearing was that the wording is
challenging and just needed to be
clarified that that's what the objective
is
yes
i mean that's what i wrote so how would
to clarify we're talking about the
actual experimental service or the
problems that might develop from the
experimental service because if we're
talking about the problems that would be
considered discriminatory if a carrier
said well we're not going to cover that
because of something about you
so
so they don't have it's not about the
insurance company covering the
experimental drug right that's
completely different
but a an injury that that is as a result
of that
um because remember it's it's it's a
it's authorized by the fda under
emergency use
okay so it's not a part of a drug trial
uh or anything like that i don't know
how that would be covered i'm sure
there's federal laws that govern that
not that
but uh just making sure that that if if
you take
a anything that anything
that is authorized under even emergency
use authorization that any injuries that
are a result of that would be covered by
your insurance company yeah and it
really would be treated like anything
else i mean sure wouldn't be able to say
we're not going to cover it because of
how we're not going to cover your
condition because of how it was caused
that would be considered discriminatory
i don't have it with me but there's been
several studies done
and several occasions across the country
that this has already happened
so ivermectin is not a uh is not an
experimental drug i've ever met has been
around for a while like the person who
who
brought it into won a nobel prize
okay for medicine for for ivermectin the
problem with ivermectin is it is one of
the most successfully used drugs
in the world ever safer than even
tylenol on a drug safety rating
but it has not been authorized for use
as a treatment for covet
okay it's been used but it is not the
fda has not officially approved it for
that use so anybody who uses it is using
it off label it's not illegal it's not
horse paste
it is
author it is an off label use and
doctors prescribe drugs for off label
use all kinds of medicines it's not an
unusual practice but for some reason
other ivermectin gets labeled horse
paste and people people are nut jobs for
taking it
and so
anybody who would use
ivermectin according to this bill if
they
ivermectin is not authorized for the
emergency authorities this is fda right
so it wouldn't it wouldn't get covered
it would not because it's not authorized
for use under emergency you thought use
authorization
it's already fda approved
that's interesting so that what you're
making argument is that we shouldn't
pass this bill because
this this i know this statute this is
the off label statute
and this bill originally in my memory
was originally it was
um
it was actually it was for cancer wasn't
it was a cancer bill
is my memory
and the and it was being pushed by the
uh cancer society
they wanted this off label
yeah were you around for that were you
around for this one there have been
several drugs that have been
developed and experimented and and use
it off label because they found an
application in cancer treatment and that
may have been it i'm not familiar with
that particular law
but this would cover for example the the
uh the cova-19 vaccines
that have been used for the last two
years now or a year and a half whatever
it is has been uh have only been
approved under emergency use
authorization
so
that's that's what we have on the market
that's what people are getting now what
was approved by the fda is a is a
variety that is not even on the market
in the us called common arty
and so what you are getting when you go
down to the clinic and get your shot is
actually authorized under emergency use
authorization so if you experience an
injury for that
the the the the motivation for this bill
would be if you are injured by that your
insurance company needs to cover that
um because there's the the concern that
uh they might deny
your your claim because you took an
and we're hearing from the hospital
their written testimony mr chairman
uh it seems to me that this bill begs
for work
uh whether it be by this committee
and by the way
representative greeson and i
have just come from a meeting with the
speaker where
your method of operation is
praised as laudatory and exemplary for
other committees
which we already knew but we appreciated
him saying that
in the sense in the special regard that
this committee actually works on fixing
bills that we deem to be deficient or
defective in contrast to other
committees the sponsors to go and fix it
which in this case might not necessarily
be the proper course of action unless we
want to work collaboratively with
collaboratively with the sponsor because
in the written testimony that was
submitted on the second by the nha
we were told and we confirmed that the
analysis of the bill is in conflict with
the language of the bill right right in
other words the stated intent of the
bill and the language of the bill
are contradictory anyway so i don't know
how much time we want to spend on trying
to fix this today
um and i don't know whether or not you
want to consult with the sponsor on how
to fix this but clearly this needs to be
fixed right
period thank you so the question
thank you
so the question is the compliment
thank you i like that part
so the question is do we want to try to
fix this in the next couple of weeks or
should we interim study it and uh yes
yes i agree okay i asked all right
all right
you're welcome okay here we go so now
so i got the right bill 1162.
okay hunt bartlett greason terry burrows
okay representative terry seconded
by representative uh
burroughs
if you want i thought i heard somebody
okay
all right uh any discussion on the
motion scene on all those in favor of
interim study please raise your hand one
okay
fix it
i'm just saying
i used to joke that other committees if
it's not 99.9 pure
they just kill it on site
and i and i always thought that it's
outrageous because
and then they would say to the sponsor
you go make the amendment
i think well no no the bill belongs to
us yes
we've just experienced this in another
venue another committee and we were in
shock talked and furthermore we were
told to fix it and then we were told we
were told to fix it and then we asked
what are we to fix and they said well
you figure it out
this is no way to do people's freshman
representative mind reading class that
day
right so that but you went away
realizing how fortunate you are we are
by the grace of god i'm here okay
all right
next up uh relative co-payment and
services rendered by a chiropractor in
this case
we do have a sponsor
you want to come on up and
since we can never really get can't get
you
being paid more
yeah yeah i guess there you go is it on
now yeah okay i'm sorry thank you
um
is we want to be
a
a provider not a specialist
that reduces the co-pays
um
and it's all about
making it easy for um patients to to get
care um
i i'll give you a good example i mean i
didn't realize i'd be having any
speaking role today so um
i had a new patient come in yesterday
and her insurance checked out that she
has a hundred dollar copay
you know that's
that's insanity when i see and we talked
about this last week about how the state
has
a special plan the teachers have a
special plan you know you're talking
five ten dollar co-pays specialists on
the state and teacher plan are thirty
dollars we run anywhere from forty to
sixty now i saw a hundred and i i would
so what what plan did she have what
company was it um you know i think it
was an anthem plan
well i
i can't uh
right
i don't know
okay
first i want to make sure everybody i'm
not sure
yeah let me change that independent
america no
okay so so basically that's what i'm
looking for it's not going to cost
you know any patient anything it's not
going to cost the insurance company
anything it should just reject reduction
in co-pays by taking us out of the
specialist category
and putting us into the
primary care
but
everybody has a copay and co-insurance
no i understand but
if you're under the specialist uh
it's it it is significantly higher
and that's what we're trying to do is
reduce it make it easy for patients to
seek care
right okay so the one thing i want to
clear up you know let everybody speak
but that when you start talking about
the other the state employees and all
those other places those are riskes no i
i understand that but i'm just i'm just
giving some examples
and then the other thing i want to say
is as as being the person who was in the
room
when we passed the legislation original
legislation dealing with chiropractic
services right where we said that if you
if you offer it you got to give it you
got to give 12 12 months you know one
month
right right that when we passed that i
again
the
deal was that insurance company that was
if they did offer it
so at that time cigna
they're in the room
at that time cigna dropped it
obviously they now carry it because they
i know she was in the room when we had
the hearing so they now carried it but
that that that it was sort of like the
consequence of the law okay
excuse me for just a sec so i'll give
you an example of um
i'm trying to think what uh insurance
company
but um it's a fifty dollar copay
and we get three dollars and ninety
cents from the insurance company
i i just think that's unfair for the for
the patient because then they they think
they've got chiropractic care and
actually they don't
right 53. so you would rather just
run the risk of
dropping the carbohydrates so it's a lot
more convenient for patients to get in
without breaking the bank
so in terms of this language here you
would what what is the word that says
that would help you on
because all i see is that
so if that happens
i'm just trying to think this through if
this if that happened if that were to
happen
the provider is is still going to charge
x number of dollars this this assumes
that the insurance company decides to
continue coverage under this change
okay that's that's right
the provider is still going to charge x
number of dollars
what it means is that the patient is
going to pay a smaller portion of the
total number of dollars that are allowed
under the contract that the insurance
company has with the provider which
means
that unless that dollar figure is
lowered in negotiation between the
insurance company and the provider the
provider the actual cost of the provider
is going to be greater because they're
going to be sharing a greater proportion
of the allowable cost because you've
reduced the copay let's say from fifty
dollars to ten dollars am i
understanding this correctly
but that's the implication i mean so on
the one hand you were saying that the
the uh the patient only has to pay ten
dollars instead of 50.
but what are the implications for the
insurance company unless the insurance
company
contracts with you or or chiropractors
to lower the allowable
fee which you then have to determine
whether you accept right and if you
don't accept it then bye-bye right i got
this correct okay thank you right so in
this current scenario you're saying if
it's a 50 deductible
and you're only getting 350 dollar copay
excuse me 50 copay and you're only
getting 3.95
somewhere in that that means well it's
called
four dollars right
that means the total amount of money you
got is 54 right
versus if you if we were to say that has
to be the same as any other physician
which is ten dollars
that doesn't mean they're gonna raise
that four dollar that four dollars
well i think that goes back to contract
negotiations then right goes back to the
absolutely and then at that point they
might say
bye bye exactly
that's that's uh that we're not going to
cover chiropractor anymore yes
representative johnson i know you want
to speak
the question
why is your green a green means too many
too many lights around i'll take
okay
so i know one of the other things is to
be able to offer chiropractic to more
people for
health benefits
am i correct that's another reason why
we were this bill was brought forward to
reduce the cost so people can get
more health benefits out of the
chiropractic unless i'm mixing it up
with another bill but no okay
i know
the insurance company i now have
they switched over because they saw the
benefits of chiropractic care
so my insurance company
my health insurance company
took our
healthcare
chiropractic and took them out of the
specialist and made them regular
providers it has done a wonders just for
my family alone
we are not seeing the doctors on a
regular basis we go
to our maintenance with our chiropractor
and it has saved us hundreds of dollars
going to a regular chiropractic going
rather than going to a doctor or a
specialist
just because of a chiropractic care and
i think
if i remember in the testimony they also
talked about those who have back injury
or knee injuries
they go to a if they can go to a
chiropractor more often
they'll be less likely to get hooked on
the
opioids and the drugs which is what we
are trying to do
in our society is to help stop that
correct
thank you
oh fargo
i have two issues
one when you um and tyler maybe you can
jump in here if you change the copay and
you keep the coverage then the insurance
company is paying more
than they were paying before because i'm
paying less and that's a drive on
yeah and
not only would the insurance company pay
more for the existing patients that they
would otherwise would have had a
less a smaller percentage of the share
you may have additional people who get
chiropractic services because they'll
see the lower co-pay and those would be
new patients visiting the chiropractor
which again would increase the cost
overall utilization the original bill
was passed the theory was if people had
better access use chiropractic care more
often
overall costs would be lower but it was
everybody assumed
lower cost sharing means you're going to
use those services more that's generally
how it works with insurance
the other issue that i see that we have
talked about for years is now you're
setting a precedent so tomorrow we're
going to have someone come in who is say
a podiatrist who says i don't want to be
a specialist anymore i should have the
same co-pay as a primary care physician
or your orthopedic guy or i mean
are we setting a president of precedence
and opening a door that any specialist
type of practice can come in and say i
don't want to have to pay the same the
nature of the profession is i think the
only other one would be a physical
therapist
because really what this problem comes
down to is that this is is something is
ongoing care you know they're getting
you're getting 12 visits a year
so you know you're not going to a
podiatrist 12 times a year you're the
only other person i know you would do
use
regular visits would be a physical
therapist
am i guessing correctly
so that would be the consequences that
physical therapists would come in and
want the same thing can i can i
so
you have to understand that chiropractic
care is not only
has a lot of health benefits but
it has and i could have brought a bunch
of studies regarding reduction of opioid
use
we are in a a pandemic with opioid abuse
right now i mean i've i've got a bill
upstairs downstairs that i'm trying to
get past um but the issue is is the
reduction of costs of medicine
offsets what we're doing and we're doing
it naturally and we're getting people
well
and it's not just about the manipulation
it's about a total lifestyle
change and
i think the health benefits just
outweigh the the negatives
okay thank you
yes representative
thank you mr chair um
i think we really appreciate what you're
offering for services but i have to go
back to what the empirical evidence
showed us
and when
michael eaton hayton came from the
insurance department they did have
a cost-sharing parity study from 2014
that sunset in 2017.
and what they said they said they found
that the
lower co-pays
did correspond with higher use of
chiropractic care
it did not offset the costs it did not
reduce
it says that
let's see
it did increase the total spending
overall
without the without significant decrease
in opioid use
and she um he did have a link to the
reports that i don't know did we receive
the link
i can't remember
but i think we have to i mean anecdotal
evidence
is great and we understand that but i
think we still have to go back to what
the real cost will be
for insurance premiums
and if we reduce the the co-pays there
is likely to be an increase in premium
so representative can i ask a question
yes absolutely yeah
the study was done by whom i didn't i
didn't catch you this came from michael
heaton at the insurance department tyler
can you help yeah so michelle was
filling in for me and talked about the
two studies we did the prior legislation
had us do a study
pretty much right after the bill passed
looking at data looking at people who
had lower cost sharing for chiropractic
services versus those who would hire and
then sort of looking at patterns among
the population so this is before the
legislation had a chance to have an
impact
then a couple of years later we looked
at the impact of the legislation again
to see whether there'd been a change
over time and in both cases you could
see increased use of the chiropractic
services um
the costs overall were higher but in
both of those studies it did there did
it appear to be a reduced use of opioids
in one of the studies at least it was um
it was not considered statistically
significant but that basically means
that you're 95 confidence not due to
sort of random variation so um i think
that the representation that it does
result in and it can cause that lower
use is probably likely although in any
of these studies coming up with sort of
the causal association is always a
little bit of a question and and she did
send us the link on
february the 3rd
i do have it in my email
along with 700 and somewhat other emails
that i haven't opened
um i can send you the links to the
report oh yeah i've got it here it is
from the insurance department
okay representative terry so i do
that
that goes to
related to cost
and
perhaps ultimately availability
of the
of coverage
we already identified that
so so i do appreciate that uh by the
same token
what i what i understand here is that
the same chiropractors want to be
treated in the same way under this bill
as
with respect to the services provided
uh by a primary care physician or an
osteopath
so i'm sure everybody here knows the
difference between an md and a do
so
when i sustained an injury and went to
an md the md recommended that i go to a
do
the do did stuff that the do was trained
to do that the md was not trained to do
then the do recommended that i might
also see a chiropractor and the services
provided by the chiropractor were very
similar to those that were provided by
the uh by the d.o
now
we already we already
provide a primary care apparently uh
co-pay and an osteopath co-pay that is
uh what should we call minimal
uh for the sake of this argument i think
we all know what this means 15 or
whatever okay entry level co-pay
whatever
so if in fact the services that are
provided by the chiropractor
are similar to those that are provided
by a do
one might ask why is a carve out given
to the to the do to be treated in the
same way as a pcp even though the pcp is
not qualified to provide these kinds of
services but not to the
to to the chiropractor and understanding
that there's been a historic
tension
in the medical field between
those who have medical degrees
md or do and those who have pursued
careers in chiropractic i don't know how
much mr truman i don't know how far down
we wanted to get into the weeds on this
but i think that what we need to hear
from
the advocate of the bill here is that
we need to receive a rationale
for why
providers
chiropractors need to be treated in the
same way
as does
perhaps even more so than than mds
as an additional consideration to the
ramifications
financially that have already been
pointed out and discussed and we all
acknowledge
yeah to me it's the 12 visits
it's the monthly visit it's fine yeah
okay um
i've been i've been in business 45 years
i i'm sorry yeah this nobody sees me
they just hear me it's like i'm on the
radio
anyway i've been uh practiced 45 years
and my initial practice uh i i started
referring and getting referrals from
orthopedic surgeons
it has grown and grown in our profession
back in the old days yeah we were witch
doctors if you want to call it that
that's no longer true i can't give you
the exact amount of schooling that we
have compared to
a pcp but it's
it's pretty significant what we do
so
what you had said i
i get a lot of referrals from from
medical doctors right now they don't
they don't i have yet to have somebody
refer to a do and have a d.o report
refer to me i'm a direct line to the
medical doctors
so i hope that
answers uh
just kind of follow up but isn't the
real reason why they're calling you a
specialist is because of the the amount
of visits that you could have on an
annual basis
representative i mr chair i have no clue
why they call us a specialist
but okay but just
okay
just to follow to clarify here by what i
meant when i was talking about i went
from an md to a do to a chiropractor
just that was incidental that was my
particular situation okay um
we understand that
that chiropractors are viewed more
favorably by those in the medical
profession whether mds or does than they
were years ago i think that's generally
well known and understood
i
the servant we're looking at the
particular service that is provided by a
chiropractor
that could also be provided by a do
to a certain extent not not exactly the
same because they don't do manipulations
right but we're in the same we're in the
same ballpark if not in the same seating
section
so
what what i'm asking is that that you
make the case that with respect to these
particular
injuries or issues
that you ought to be treated in the same
way
with respect to the co-payment
as do's and mds
that would be a level playing field and
that's what we need
correct because
i'm sorry whether it's 12 visits or 120
right
i mean
i i look at an orthopedic surgeon as a
specialist
okay
i don't look at a do as a specialist
i don't look at a medical doctor well
that's why i believe that so primary
care physician and osteopath are
effectively lumped or named together
well it also could be a nurse
practitioner it's the third well yes
because they're all three years because
this is 2022 nurse practitioner in there
representative griezmann
thank you mr chairman thank you for
answering our questions
uh if i recall correctly you stated when
you when we first heard the bill
that you are actually a first phone call
that a person can make that they you
don't have to be referred to
correct so you are in effect already a
primary care provider
that you can refer someone to someone
else if it's something that you are not
capable of providing but otherwise i can
call you directly book an appointment
so you are already a primary care
correct
okay so let me articulate how i see this
bill at this moment and we can see where
we want to go here
um historically uh us republicans have
said that we are opposed to health
insurance mandates
this bill is technically a mandate
because we are mandating what the
compensation the premium you know the
compensation for the physician so just
want you to know that you're you're
you're you're crossing that line that
people would say you know that you're
not supposed to be doing that okay
what's important here
is
that the the the uh the game the role of
the dice that we're doing here is if we
were to pass this
we are
theoretically now making it more
affordable for a person to uh go to to
do the chiropractic visits
therefore that increases utilization
there'll be more people using it
you know someone says well if i'm if i
if one thing if i'm ten bucks versus
fifty dollars you know um you know i'll
use something more so
the risk is excess utilization but we're
arguing is that's a good thing because
we'd much rather them do this than go to
that surgeon who uh want to cut you open
and cost hundreds of thousand dollars to
fix your back
and in that balance
the interesting twist to this is
is that now we're running
the insurance
company
is going to then decide whether they
want to continue to offer this benefit
so they're going to balance that off by
how important it is to people that they
get chiropractic coverage
versus how much decreases that
utilization
the premium that that's being used and
then saying oh boy this is really going
to have an impact on premium so we're
better off just dropping it and let the
person just pay to the chiropractor let
me further muddy the waters mr chairman
um by
observing
that what is being
proposed here
in this legislation is in fact i believe
already taking place
within within the insurance industry
with respect to this particular
profession
and the and i cite this as
uh under my plan
i pay fifteen dollars co-pay
for a primary care physician i pay forty
for a specialist and i paid 20 dollars
they already have a separation so
there's already a separation
[Music]
that's being recognized by anthem i
can't speak to other incumbents but
something is going on even without us
getting involved here and i'm not saying
we shouldn't i'm just saying there's
stuff going on that that that
that should not
that should should not leave us with the
misimpression
that they're that that all insurance
companies are charging
a uh specialist co-pay for chiropractic
services thank you are you are you
medicare
am i what medicare your medicare
advantage plan yeah i'm medicare
advantage and my
my plan says my pcp visit is
zero
you must specialist is 30 yeah yeah
because i'm an advantage right
especially this is 30. you must have a
different plan than i do okay i'll have
to look into that yeah right this is the
stride stride plan so we have harvard
pilgrim and whether i go to my pcp
or if i go to my chiropractor it's the
same co-pay
and i have unlimited visits
and
let me tell you i go to my chiropractor
before i go to my pcp okay so you're
making the argument that the law is fine
as it is
the insurance no but more insurance
companies should be doing this because i
think it's a benefit to the people
they're doing it voluntarily without
having to be told that they have to do
it right but if we can yeah
right
that's reverend
so is is a is a chiropractor deter uh
considered a specialist
by statute
or by the insurance companies insurance
company okay so one insurance company
can say you're a specialist one can say
you're not
or one could carve it out and treat you
something differently or or
yeah you're your own your own thing
that's cool
you do you right
okay okay
what do you think john
would you believe
i am a chiropractic patient
i believe uh
the representative knows who i go to
down in derry chiropractic
um i started going there many many years
ago before
medicare before i was on medicare and
now that i am on medicare it's been
great
i have spinal stenosis
and
it helps me
immeasurably
going to see him once a month
and uh
getting checked out and realigned and
stretched and pulled and pushed and it
works
because if it didn't i certainly
wouldn't be here would you believe
yes i would okay
all right representative burrows
yeah i mean this has been alluded to but
when you were talking about the
insurance companies weighing the cost
benefits you know i think we need to go
back to when chiropractors were
considered boogeymen and i think they
were maybe you'd agree that that they
were being sent to surgeons
um and and the astronomical costs that
that poses to insurance companies is is
that true that they would normally have
gone to a surgeon rather tend to yes
yeah
so
that's important thank you
okay anybody else want to
comment yeah represent evan
yeah i too have been to chiropractors
over the years and i appreciate your
profession
and i believe it is true that uh going
to a chiropractor in some cases can
reduce uh or eliminate the need to go to
a surgeon right
and in the insurance companies
their desire to reduce costs for
medical care and and provide lower
premiums they would factor that in i
believe in their business model
they would look at those
you know maybe even do some in-depth
studying that we're not capable of doing
here
and factor that in so
you know my thought is
trust the insurance companies
you know
to some degree into uh
deciding
uh how to incentivize people to go
either to a chiropractor or to a surgeon
because we know surgery is very
expensive right so it's
uh it's necessary sometimes but it can
be a lot more expensive than 12 visits
to a chiropractor
so okay
i don't think we're ready to vote do
anything yet today on this one so we'll
we'll bring this up again thanks for
your time yeah appreciate it yeah and
and anything you take back from what you
heard discussion feel free to email us
and i'm going to go to the speaker's
office right now
i told you you're right through the
calls over here
okay
okay so the situation with this panda is
that
in the wisdom of the legislature when we
pass this study to monitor
the diagnostic code we sunsetted it
after five years
and so with this bill is to remove the
sunset so that we keep studying it or
keep
representative parker
i i think and i i i worked with becky on
this a little bit the sunset clause was
an end of 2024 we would stop providing
coverage for it not stop no there is no
there's no
no it's just the it's just the study
right you mean tyler might am i doing
this correctly
no the
requirement to cover
treatment including the ivig is what
would sunset
that being said if it's deteriorative
sort of the
medical disagreement in the community
about what is considered medically
necessary shifts toward this is clearly
a condition it's clearly there's clearly
medically necessary treatment then we
would consider it discriminatory for an
insurance company not to cover it i
think the sunset date was considered a
compromise because there's a lot of
uncertainty about how much it would cost
to increase coverage um in situations
that could be concerned about medical
necessity treatment patterns everything
else because that led to the
conversations about how the insurance
department would collect data to look at
the company
associated with it which proved to be
problematic using the claims data and
the diagnosis code
but i think wasn't it true that that we
because they weren't using a specific
code we couldn't get the data
that we wanted we couldn't isolate what
the autoimmune deficiency was costing us
but we also didn't see an increase in
any other code that would indicate that
it was so expensive that premiums were
going to skyrocket which is why they
were afraid to approve this in the first
place
so my concern is that a lot of people
have benefited from having this coverage
and if we take it away from them
a lot of people are going to be hurt by
that because this this is a very real
problem and thankfully we you know we
have been
covering under insurance for the last
couple years if we take that away a lot
of people are going to be hurt by it and
i can't see that it's hurt the state or
impacted premiums or anything like that
so
i think we have to be really clear here
you're seeing it is it is a mandate that
and so your fear is if we let the thing
sunset
then that mandate's gone and there'll be
somebody who would not get coverage
that's not what i heard from you you're
you're saying we don't even have a
diagnostic code for this so we don't
even know
if anybody's been diagnosed with it we
have a non-specific diagnosis code when
we looked at the claims data there were
a lot of adults that were coded with
that diagnosis code the overall numbers
seem to be relatively stable but sorting
out which patients are actually true
pandas is not something we would be able
to do using the claims data right so the
question is how do you know that that
that they wouldn't get coverage
well i
i don't but if we repeal this then
what why would we repeal
you know we said that we were gonna they
weren't providing coverage
we told them we we created this mandate
that i remember the discussions yeah
so that we would we would they would
have coverage and not if we repeal
why would we want to repeal this because
well i my memory was there was nobody
who didn't get
coverage
the problem was
that there was no diagnosis
and so that's why passing the mandate
seemed so questionable to me
because because we didn't we didn't even
know whether anybody's actually being
diagnosed no i think the concern was
that there was a a particular type of
therapy for this that right there was a
particular therapy that's at harvard and
harvard was adamantly opposed to that
therapy it was a blood thing and there
were people who said that that that was
not a good course of action and there
were doctors who testified that yes
it was and it had provided relief for
people
and that was the big
question that we had before we passed it
but we did
no i understand i think you guys were in
the majority at the time and i was in
the minority
now
can the insurance companies not
reimburse people for their treatment for
so if the if the mandate did sunset an
insurance company could potentially say
okay the treatment is not medically
necessary the
patient the member would have the
ability to go through an appeals process
which could go to an external set of
clinicians i know that one i wrote that
law right and those clinicians could
also agree with the insurer that yes
this is a there's a lack of clarity and
it's not obvious that this is medically
necessary treatment in which case the
insurance company would be on pretty
solid ground they could also say yes it
absolutely there's been enough
development with this disease
identifying it clarifying that ivig
treatment is appropriate in which case
the insurance company would have to
cover it
but do we want to take that might do we
want to take that risk and why would we
get representative bartlett
thank you mr chair i'm just wondering if
we could call um paula rogers up she was
very involved in this um in these
discussions
um
okay come on up paul this um
expensive
treatment and um how anthem would look
at it right if this were um so what what
happened to this mysterious treatment
that harvard didn't like so so i think
if you look at the biologically based
chapter biologically they pull the mic a
the um if you look at the chapter i
think it reads something along the line
of pandas
is tagged on after
autism perhaps
so there's a there's a
number of mental conditions behavioral
conditions that are formally recognized
and then there's the little tag of
immunoglobulin therapy
is that correct tyler you're looking at
so i think what you're trying to get at
is we might want to get rid of
immunoglobulin therapy but pandas needs
to be covered
and pandas is covered so the problem is
i suspect there are a lot of people um i
think i would reference the fact that
the american academy of pediatrics has
recognized pandas where the dispute
comes is how to treat it
and so you know there are a number of
indicators that a child may have
a pandas or pandas-like condition
and the typical treatment would be
antibiotics a steroid maybe some
behavioral health assistance maybe some
family counseling to deal with the
behavioral aspects of the disease
the real
question last time around was this
immunoglobulin therapy
so i can understand why you feel well if
you
rub out the entire language pandas is
somehow evaporated
so maybe there's a middle ground and i
anthem's not taking a position on this i
can assure you
um we've had no complaints about our
inadequacy about treating
or request work or responding to
physician interests and treatments
the follow-up could could you also be
able to confirm that there's not been a
a spike in um claims
costs
when this this expensive treatment is
covered it's not a common condition so
the the expenses would be there
over the course of the child's
experience with this condition
and maybe some therapies you getting up
toward the immunoglobulin ivig and
aphresis with the expensive treatments
i don't think we're providing those
specifically or have that we're
providing
immunoglobulin
and tyler's looked and he will see the
use of that but the problem is you can't
trace it back to a diagnosis where you
can say this is pandas it could be any
number of things
so that's the
complexity of it
so you could look at that language and
say
maybe immunoglobulin is not really
necessary
but the pandas seems to be in some
quarters something that they would like
yes
sure
so i'll try to give perhaps a family's
perspective on this so it is really two
different issues and pandas is uh
something and i think if you ask most
families
their number one stressor is actually
getting proper coverage which is it is a
battle with the insurance company
particularly once the condition reaches
the level of needing ivig so some fairly
new data that
i picked up from a consortium of people
out of california of
caregivers around pandas
only about 10 percent of the most
chronic cases require ivig and actually
the treatment prior to reaching that
level
is antibiotics are things that are quite
affordable and usually covered within
policies the problem is as soon as
your child or even adults now reach that
level
ivig the cost escalates significantly to
the point that
i can say for our daughter when she died
just prior to starting those treatments
but we're looking at a 32 000 out of
pocket expense
and
all the research that's happened since
um
has really progressed towards ivy being
a very effective treatment for a chronic
case of autoimmune and it's not just
pandas there's other autoimmune
conditions that are currently using ivig
effectively as well
so
really what we're looking at is two
things one is that we're sort of at that
awkward period and i would say a
parallels or long-term covet we all kind
of feel it's there that is something
there but how are we going to put a
number to that or be able to quantify
that when we still
don't have a great diagnostic tool for
it so it's still somewhat of a clinical
diagnosis of whether
you need ivig or not and i can tell you
that most physicians are quite reluctant
to recommend it
unless they feel it's absolutely
critical because actually
most of the patients they see
not all of them would be covered under
the new hampshire statute
because
they're being covered by out-of-state
or or self-insured plans and it's not
unusual to hear them going through
three levels of appeals and then
be declined and actually the
the physicians that are having to do
this are spending an inorder amount of
time
just fighting to get coverage and to get
reimbursement and even if they're
successful it offer it's awful usually
it's through a very long succession of
appeal processes so the two components
are important and really what i think
we're asking is that
we're sort of at that stage where
there's a fair amount of research coming
down the pike octa pharma is in a stage
3 clinical trial today but the results
probably won't be
available for
you know to the public for two to three
years minimum
so it's really giving a little bit more
time for the research to present itself
we now have a diagnostic the icd code
89.89
which is sort of a non-specific but does
indicate pandas as a diagnosis
in
icd-2023 i believe pandas will have its
own diagnostic code
so there is progress towards actually
being able to make the data easier to
find and easier to report against and
really all we're asking is
a little bit more time if if the repeal
of the sunset is
sunset is not possible
an extension such that some of these
trials that are underway would actually
generate some data in the meantime
the impact to that 10 percent of the
families that need it could be
and typically once you reach that level
uh a child is unable to go to school if
they're going to school there's a
there's a lot of other factors they
can't get daycare
the the the condition is such that the
ig is a
basically a life changer for for the kid
and also for the family frankly it has
to bear that burden
so i think we're really really asking
for is just a little bit more time in
the meantime
families in new hampshire are benefiting
from it
but there's also many families in new
hampshire that aren't
covered by the bill because they have
out of state insurance that are
and what i would suggest is that if you
wanted to study this more
since this bill was passed dartmouth has
become has opened up a pandas clinic
officially
and i've asked them to start collecting
data on
what they're doing which is you know
better than nothing
but i think that could be a source for
us also to have an ongoing discussion
about that it certainly is a compromise
yes representative fargo um
so so by the passage of the original
bill
it has helped families in new hampshire
and continues to do that
right so those
exactly so those families that live in
new hampshire and are covered by a plan
that is registered in the state to do
business estate have benefited from the
plan
and and anthem i think has said they're
neutral which would suggest that it's
tolerable to them i think the other
insurance companies have also not
been very vocal about saying that this
is
a
a detrimental bill to to their ability
to to support it
so i guess my position is why would we
want to sunset this if it's working and
it's not hurting anyone or costing
it's not impacting premiums it's not
well how do you know it's not impacting
premiums
i just asked tyler if he saw any
any effect from it
that would affect premiums in any way
and he said he can't even identify
where it is because
right so how do you know how if we don't
get identified how do you how do you
predict premium how do you predict
utilization just simply if on something
that's so intangible as this
yes representative bartlett well
insurance companies um do keep track of
large claims the underwriters are
flagged when they see um something
coming in and the insurance and they
will use that in their rate making
process
so that if
the insurance department is not
made aware that there are some big
spikes
regarding a treatment like this i would
think that that would be fairly
good evidence that it's not
directly affecting premium
okay
representative emma did you have
something
yeah just looking the repeal doesn't
happen until july 1 2024 so there's two
more uh there's a whole other
legislative term there's two years to do
something even if we don't do anything
today right so
but you said maybe more time would uh
give us some more data
um
but even if we do nothing
you know there's importance but not
necessarily urgency at this point to do
anything because the sun sets oh yeah i
was thinking i thought the sunset was
now yeah
okay
so
okay so so all right well we'll we'll
talk let's talk about this some more
we'll have to take this up now
okay
all right uh relative to pharmacy
yeah
who would like to make the itl motion
all right represent ammon
with apologies with apologies to
representative delemus if she's in the
room she i think she's
and uh seconded by me
okay any discussion on the motion of itl
all those in favor raise your hand
fifty four by six okay
okay
great
sorry just uh going forward so um
starting
not next week but the week after
this committee meets on wednesdays and
thursdays
and i will be scheduling all the
subcommittees all the
the free subcommittees
um
i think the next week i'll just try to
push through them and and not ex
schedule exec session until
the following week so it'll be like the
yeah next week we're
we're all we're up manchester united
the 23rd 24th okay yeah so there's
another yet
then there'll be another week after that
yeah okay so that week we'll do
subcommittees and then the following
week will be subcommittees and an exec
session
yes
anyways right so that one's scheduled
well i mean we'll see see we might we
might have some subcommittees pushed
into there too but because you know me i
i like to exec sessions shouldn't take
too long
[Laughter]
we got to be finished at that point yeah
yeah
no i i'm there the next i'm there for
the next week that
yeah
so i i feel like we have all the time
and i don't even know whether we're
going to get an er we're going to get
one of these builds that we'll take
action on
next week i don't know if we'll get one
of those and if that does then we'd have
i have to
i have to squeeze it in there somehow
so all right
okay
how
yes
i
[Music]
okay
great
yes
so
you